Hi, this is Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast. Unfortunately, Alice is not able to be with us today, but we have our guest, Sandra Del Castillo. And correct me if I'm saying that wrong or incorrectly. Is that right? No, you did it. That's great. Del Castillo. Nice.
你好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel Blackstock。很遗憾，Alice今天无法参加，但我们请到了嘉宾Sandra Del Castillo。如果我读错了，请纠正我。是这样吗？不，你读对了。太棒了。Del Castillo。很好。
And I'm surprised and delighted. So, yeah. She has a podcast that I like, which is how I found her, which is the Blue Medicine Journal, which we're working on getting in more podcast libraries right now. It's just in a couple. But if you Google it, you'll find it. And she is a specialist in depth psychology and Mesoamerican mythology as you know, from an archetypal perspective. So I'm sure that this conversation is going to be really interesting. I'm so happy that you're here with us. And thank you so much for being here.
我感到既惊讶又高兴。所以，是的。她有一个我很喜欢的播客，我就是通过它找到她的，叫《蓝色医学期刊》（Blue Medicine Journal），我们目前正努力让它进入更多的播客平台。现在只有几个平台有。但如果你用谷歌搜索，就能找到它。如你所知，她是一位深度心理学和中美洲神话专家，是从原型视角出发的。所以我相信这次谈话会非常有趣。我很高兴你能来到这里。非常感谢你的到来。
So you got anything before we get started? Do you want to give an introduction of yourself or any questions about where this should go? Thank you, Joel. First of all, thanks for finding me and tuning into my podcast, Blue Medicine Journal, a Jungian podcast. My background is from Pacifica Graduate Institute. I got my master's and PhD there. And what I did, my dissertation on the Mexican Day of the Dead from a Jungian perspective. So in that process, I was able to delve really deeply into the Mesoamerican, which became a passion and began just leading me through the entire process.
在我们开始之前，你有什么想说的吗？你想做一个自我介绍，或者对这次谈话的方向有什么疑问吗？谢谢你，Joel。首先，感谢你找到我并收听我的播客《蓝色医学期刊》，这是一个荣格心理学播客。我的背景来自太平洋研究生院（Pacifica Graduate Institute）。我在那里获得了硕士和博士学位。我的博士论文是关于从荣格视角研究墨西哥亡灵节的。在这个过程中，我能够深入研究中美洲文化，这成了我的热情所在，并开始引导我完成整个过程。
So, and like I said, or like you said, it's through a Jungian lens. So it's not that I have this vast amount of knowledge and expertise in what is the Mesoamerican, but rather what is the Mesoamerican through a Jungian lens. And that to me is what makes it key, you know, and it allows me to show its relevance today as we, you know, find ourselves in this Kairos moment, this between worlds moment or, you know, sixth grade extinction. The liminal space, you know, kind of like the Day of the Dead,
正如我所说，或者正如你所说，这是通过荣格的视角。所以并不是说我在中美洲文化方面拥有渊博的知识和专业技能，而是通过荣格的视角来看待中美洲文化。对我来说，这才是关键所在，它让我能够展示其在当下的相关性，因为我们发现自己正处于这个“凯洛斯”（Kairos）时刻，这个处于两个世界之间的时刻，或者说，第六次大灭绝。这种阈限空间，有点像亡灵节，
you know, this overlapping of two worlds. But so when you say, you know, archetypal, I'm hearing you mean that um you're you're looking more at the kind of you know projective and you know timeless elements of the psyche in the mythology but you're saying you're not quite like an anthropologist or an archaeologist or a historian on you know the whole history of mesoamerican stuff so when you when you're coming at that um you know to look at it i mean do you use mainly Aztec or the similarities between the Aztec and the Maya, like the heroic twins? Or do you go back to the Olmecs and the Toltecs?
你知道，这是两个世界的重叠。所以当你提到“原型”时，我理解你的意思是，你更多地是在神话中观察心理的投射和永恒元素，但你说你并不完全像人类学家、考古学家或历史学家那样研究中美洲的全部历史。那么，当你从这个角度切入时，你主要是使用阿兹特克文化，还是阿兹特克和玛雅之间的相似之处，比如英雄双胞胎？还是你会追溯到奥尔梅克和托尔特克文明？
What is your area of interest outside of the Day of the Dead? I do tend to focus on the Maya and the Aztec because they're the most accessible. My, although I am very interested in the Olmec as well and the Toltec, of course, you know, that's where we find the roots of Quetzalcoatl, right? Who was both a mythic figure, one of the creator gods, and also the historic god man. So there's two different figures of Quetzalcoatl, but coming from the Toltec culture. I also have interest in the Purépecha, which is my ancestral heritage.
除了亡灵节，你感兴趣的领域是什么？我确实倾向于关注玛雅和阿兹特克，因为它们最容易接触到。虽然我也对奥尔梅克和托尔特克非常感兴趣，当然，那是我们发现羽蛇神（Quetzalcoatl）根源的地方，对吧？他既是一个神话人物，是创世神之一，也是历史上的神人。所以羽蛇神有两个不同的形象，但都源自托尔特克文化。我也对普雷佩查（Purépecha）文化感兴趣，这是我的祖先遗产。
So that's from the state of Michoacán. On my father's side, my father was 100% Purépecha. So when I had the privilege of living in Michoacán for six years, I was able to delve into the myth and the ritual and the indigenous medicine and indigenous ritual in that area and be able to participate in ceremonies at the ritual sites. And it was, to me, it was one of the most learning experiences I've ever had. And of course that region is renowned for its Mexican day of the dead, which helped inspire my dissertation.
那是来自米却肯州。我父亲那边，我父亲是百分之百的普雷佩查人。所以当我有幸在米却肯州生活了六年时，我能够深入研究那里的神话、仪式、本土医学和本土仪式，并能够参加仪式场所的庆典。对我来说，这是我经历过的最深刻的学习体验之一。当然，那个地区以其墨西哥亡灵节而闻名，这也启发了我的博士论文。
Although death would have never been my first conscious choice, it certainly became the unconscious choice. Pacific is a good place for that so i guess my first question is legends of the hidden temple is it historically accurate or not well i can't show from the 90s i don't know that's a good question i it's not it's a joke it's a it was a game show where they would have kids they had a what is it a giant talking stone head called olmec was like the announcer. And then the kids would have to like run and get a prize. I don't know.
虽然死亡从来不是我最初有意识的选择，但它确实成了无意识的选择。太平洋研究生院是做这个的好地方，所以我猜我的第一个问题是，《隐藏神庙的传说》（Legends of the Hidden Temple）在历史上准确吗？我不确定，那是90年代的节目，我不知道，这是个好问题。不，那是个玩笑，那是一个游戏节目，他们会让孩子们参加，有一个巨大的会说话的石头头像叫奥尔梅克，就像播音员一样。然后孩子们必须跑去拿奖品。我不知道。
It was like on TV in like 94. Oh, my God. That's hilarious. I have no idea. I was living in Mexico at the time. You're hanging out with the real Olmec head. Yeah. Well, actually, when I was living in Veracruz, because I got to live in four different states in Mexico which was just an
那是在94年左右的电视节目。天哪。太搞笑了。我不知道。我当时住在墨西哥。你和真正的奥尔梅克头像在一起。是的。嗯，实际上，当我住在韦拉克鲁斯时，因为我有幸在墨西哥的四个不同州生活过，那是一段
amazing experience for over a period of 15 years and one of the places I lived was in the state of Veracruz in the capital of Jalapa where one of the largest anthropological or archaeological museums second to the one in Mexico City is and that's where the enormous Olmec heads are. And I actually got to perform a visual theater piece in that phenomenal museum. And it is an experience of the numinous when you're around the Olmec heads. And the Olmec, that is an Olmec site, right? It's where that museum is,
超过15年的惊人经历，我居住的地方之一是韦拉克鲁斯州的首府哈拉帕，那里有仅次于墨西哥城的最大的考古博物馆之一，巨大的奥尔梅克头像就在那里。我实际上还在那个非凡的博物馆里表演了一场视觉戏剧。当你身处奥尔梅克头像周围时，那是一种神圣的体验。奥尔梅克，那是一个奥尔梅克遗址，对吧？博物馆就在那里，
whereas the one in Mexico City is in Tenochtitlan is the Aztec temple. Yeah, absolutely. What's interesting to me about the archaeology there is like the the the olmecs and the toltecs like the aztecs knew about those empires and they kind of their kings would link their ancestry to those kings you know probably uh it probably was not real but you know they would pretend you know like we pretend well i'm and somehow you know affiliated with this ancestral line but they they had those artifacts around you know so they were digging up you know those things for inspiration i mean you found where there's pieces of jade and things that have been repurposed not jade what am i thinking of it's the bluestone uh i don't know you found
而墨西哥城的那个是在特诺奇蒂特兰，是阿兹特克神庙。是的，绝对。关于那里的考古学，有趣的是，阿兹特克人知道奥尔梅克和托尔特克这些帝国，他们的国王会把自己的血统与那些国王联系起来，你知道，可能那不是真的，但他们会假装，就像我们假装与某个祖先血统有关一样。但他们周围确实有那些文物，所以他们会挖掘那些东西来寻找灵感。我的意思是，你发现有玉石碎片和被重新利用的东西，不是玉石，我在想什么？是蓝石，我不知道，你发现了
places where they had dug things up from the olmecs and then repurposed it and brought it into the other things. So can you say anything about the difference in those cultures? I guess we don't know a ton outside of archaeological findings about Olmec mythology, whereas Aztec, the Spanish do write some of it down. What we know is that the Olmec was considered in Latin America or Mesoamerica like the first. And I think arising around 1200 BCE. And one of the things that Joseph Campbell says in his book, The Mythic Image, he talks about these ancient cultures that were, had a social and political order that was celestially based.
他们从奥尔梅克人那里挖掘出来并重新利用并引入其他事物的地方。所以你能说说这些文化之间的区别吗？我想除了考古发现外，我们对奥尔梅克神话了解不多，而阿兹特克神话，西班牙人确实记录了一些。我们所知道的是，奥尔梅克在拉丁美洲或中美洲被认为是第一个。我认为它出现在公元前1200年左右。约瑟夫·坎贝尔在他的书《神话形象》中提到，这些古代文化拥有基于天象的社会和政治秩序。
Yeah. And it began, this is archetypal in nature, and it began as he, in his findings, in around the 4th century BCE and with the in Mesopotamia with the ziggurats for us a certain class of priesthood that were priests and kings astronomers astrologers that after careful observation of the planets they were able to derive this Celestialially based social and political order. And religious, you know afterwards in creed egypt india china greece you know throughout the world without the use of the
是的。它始于——这本质上是原型的——它始于，正如他在公元前4世纪左右的发现，在美索不达米亚，随着金字形神塔的出现，出现了一个特定的祭司阶层，他们是祭司、国王、天文学家和占星家，在仔细观察行星后，他们能够推导出这种基于天象的社会和政治秩序。还有宗教，你知道，后来在埃及、印度、中国、希腊，你知道，在世界各地，没有使用
internet you know i mean there's where you see the archetypal nature it always spirals back around and it's you know it sprouts forth and so this sprouted forth in 1200 BCE in Mesoamerica, and it just sort of spread. And so this is the kind of thing that I look for in, whether it was with the Aztecs or the Mayas or the Toltecs, this kind of correlation to me, I think is the most profound. And I find the most relevant, because these were aligned with the cosmos. So we saw the world order, you know, in alignment with the cosmos that we've effectively been cut off from since the Cartesian, an important part of human evolution, you know, to sort of distinguish us from the participation mystique, you know, and find ourselves, you know, as individuals. And yet at the same time, we lost our, well, the world soul, right? The anima mundi. We lost connection with that. And so as we, to me, my search back is to glean this archetypal wisdom that was lost through
互联网，你知道，这就是你看到原型本质的地方，它总是螺旋式地回旋，它萌芽了，所以这在公元前1200年的中美洲萌芽，并开始传播。所以这就是我在阿兹特克、玛雅或托尔特克文化中寻找的东西，这种相关性对我来说是最深刻的。我发现它最相关，因为这些与宇宙是对齐的。所以我们看到的世界秩序与我们自笛卡尔以来实际上被切断的宇宙是对齐的，这是人类进化中重要的一部分，你知道，将我们与“参与神秘”（participation mystique）区分开来，找到我们作为个体的自我。然而与此同时，我们失去了世界灵魂，对吧？（Anima Mundi）。我们失去了与它的联系。所以对我来说，我的探索是去收集那些通过
the conquest and I consider the real gold and at this you know crucial moment in time something that we need to learn from something that we need to to readapt I think was it like in in the 1990, the former Czech president, Vaclav Havel, was giving a keynote speech to the students at Stanford. And he talked about this. He talked about the importance of a world democracy formed from the celestially based, let's say, unity once again. That's the only way that we would ever have it. I think, you know, as humanity finds ourselves in this, you know, Kairos moment, what Jung called the Kairos moment, I think that, you know, and let me explain a little bit about that in terms of
征服而丢失的原型智慧，我认为这是真正的黄金，在这个关键时刻，我们需要从中学习，我们需要重新适应。我想是在1990年，前捷克总统瓦茨拉夫·哈维尔在斯坦福大学对学生发表主题演讲时谈到了这一点。他谈到了建立在再次基于天象的统一之上的世界民主的重要性。这是我们唯一能实现它的方式。我认为，当人类发现自己处于这个“凯洛斯”时刻，荣格所说的凯洛斯时刻时，我认为，让我解释一下关于
the kairos, a Greek word meaning opportune moment, right? And back in the 1960s, Jung, I think, was probably in his 80s by that point, but he sensed this pervasive mood of destruction and renewal that was haunting the, you know, the humanity, Western mind anyway. And he, looking forward, he felt that it was an ideal time for what he called a metamorphosis of the gods. Now, that's a mythopoetic way of saying, you know, for changing of worldview, right? Of the fundamental principles and symbols that define our era. wisdoms that have ruled and formed order in ancient civilizations and puts us once again attuned to the world soul, to the ensouled cosmos, which we've been cut off from. We've been disenchanted.
凯洛斯，一个希腊词，意思是“适时的时刻”，对吧？在20世纪60年代，荣格当时可能已经80多岁了，但他感觉到一种弥漫的破坏与更新的情绪正在困扰着人类，至少是西方人的思想。他展望未来，觉得这是他所说的“诸神蜕变”的理想时机。这是一种神话诗意的方式，意思是改变世界观，改变定义我们时代的根本原则和符号。这些智慧曾统治并形成古代文明的秩序，并使我们再次与世界灵魂、与有灵魂的宇宙保持一致，而我们已经与它隔绝了。我们已经失去了魔力。
So I think that's part of my work is a form of re-enchantment reclaiming in the now what we've lost but you know so Jung called in in the red book he said giving birth to the ancient in a new time is the task that's the salvation and um it's like giving birth to a new world and that's that's in essence I think what depth psychologists are looking for now i mean your program your the the podcast that you you run you know you're looking for that you're you're talking about um the to the detail of what does architecture look like yeah and and what is to me that's one of the things that I also grasp from Mesoamerica. Well, I mean, I think depth psychology informs all aspects of human existence because, you know, there's these, just like you're taking, what are you doing in depth psychology? You have a patient,
所以我认为这是我工作的一部分，是一种重新赋予魔力的形式，在当下找回我们失去的东西。荣格在《红书》中说，在新的时代孕育古老的东西是我们的任务，那是救赎。这就像孕育一个新世界，我认为这本质上是深度心理学家现在所寻找的。我的意思是，你的节目，你运营的播客，你正在寻找那个，你在谈论建筑是什么样子的，对我来说，这也是我从中美洲领悟到的东西之一。嗯，我认为深度心理学涵盖了人类存在的各个方面，因为，就像你在深度心理学中所做的那样，你有一个病人，
they're, you know, usually older by the time they make it into Jungian analysis, you're starting to say, okay, well, here's the patterns in your life you kind of have to be alive a little while before we see those patterns and and then then they're like well what do i do with those and you're like well i don't know i'm not a cognitive therapist you just notice them and then you can't unnotice them you know we can't undo what we just did and then they're like well i get i tried this i tried that and it doesn't work and i can't change them well i'm angry i'll just put it down oh well no they're still there somebody continues to work through these things until there is able to kind of be a breaking and restructuring um you know but people work the same way you know we we have
他们通常在进入荣格分析时已经年纪较大，你开始说，好吧，这是你生活中的模式，你必须活一段时间才能看到这些模式，然后他们会问，我该怎么处理这些？你会说，我不知道，我不是认知治疗师，你只需要注意到它们，然后你就无法再忽视它们了。我们无法撤销我们刚刚所做的事情，然后他们会说，我试过这个，试过那个，但没用，我无法改变它们。我很生气，我只是放下它，哦，不，它们还在那里。有人继续处理这些事情，直到能够实现某种打破和重组，但人们的工作方式是一样的，我们有
these patterns and civilization that are bigger than one life or one city or one nation or one millennium you know they go back and which is you're you're talking about there at the beginning of um most mythological, the fusion of the kind of religious and logical systems is science and religion, which weren't seen as separate entities back then, you know, it was just knowledge was people projecting on the stars.
文明中比一个生命、一个城市、一个国家或一个千年更宏大的模式。它们可以追溯到很久以前，这正是你在一开始谈到的，大多数神话中宗教和逻辑系统的融合是科学和宗教，在当时它们并不被视为独立的实体，知识只是人们在星星上的投射。
They see these patterns, the patterns continue to happen. Well, why are they there? You know, what is the explanation for that? And then we start to have the central myth, you know,
他们看到这些模式，模式持续发生。好吧，它们为什么在那里？你对那个有什么解释？然后我们开始有了核心神话，
there's China, Aztecs, everyone has it. I don't know if it's apocryphal um but i've heard a story that there was like a a missionary that like went to the aztecs and thought oh these primitive people don't know anything about um you know astronomy but uh really they had a calendar that was so accurate it didn't even need a leap year. It was better than the European calendar. And so he told them, oh, well, you need to convert to Christianity because there's going to be an eclipse.
中国、阿兹特克人，每个人都有。我不知道这是否是伪经，但我听说过一个故事，有一个传教士去了阿兹特克人那里，心想，哦，这些原始人对天文学一无所知，但实际上他们有一个非常精确的历法，甚至不需要闰年。它比欧洲的历法还要好。所以他告诉他们，哦，你们需要皈依基督教，因为会有日食。
I can predict it because my God told me. And they're like, we know there's going to be an eclipse too, dude. And so they just killed him. You know? No, I have no idea. I know I've said that story, but it's a good one. I have no idea. Yeah. I mean, story, but it's a good one. I have no idea. Yeah.
我可以预测它，因为我的上帝告诉了我。他们说，我们也知道会有日食，伙计。然后他们就把他杀了。你知道吗？不，我不知道。我知道我讲过那个故事，但它是个好故事。我不知道。是的。我的意思是，故事，但它是个好故事。我不知道。是的。
I mean, the fact that any, I mean, what do we know about our neighbors to the south, really, other than what's been taught, you know, in our history books, which is a general, let's say, emphasis on their shadow. We know really nothing about... Well, it's such a through-a-glass-darkly thing because the Spaniards are writing down what Aztecs believed in order to say that it's bad, so they're sort of embellishing the worst parts, but you can maybe see a grain of truth through it. Another one,
我的意思是，除了历史书中教给我们的内容之外，我们对南方的邻居到底了解多少？历史书通常强调他们的阴暗面。我们对……了解甚少。这就像透过深色的玻璃看东西，因为西班牙人记录阿兹特克人的信仰是为了说它是坏的，所以他们是在美化最糟糕的部分，但你也许能从中看到一丝真相。另一个，
I don't know if this is apocryphal, but have you read James Maffey's book, Aztec Philosophy? No, I haven't. He's an archaeologist, so he's coming at it from... But he says basically that all of the worldview, we are thinking of it from kind of a Eurocentric perspective as gods or whatever, like it's a Greek pantheon.
我不知道这是否是伪经，你读过詹姆斯·马菲（James Maffey）的书《阿兹特克哲学》吗？没有，我没读过。他是一位考古学家，所以他是从……但他基本上说，所有的世界观，我们是从欧洲中心主义的角度将其视为神或其他什么，就像希腊万神殿一样。
But that wasn't really it. It was this interconnected energy that they sort of saw energy as being just this pervasive thing that was sort of at tension with itself. Sometimes you have the twins that are opposites that have to, you know, get along to create the world and that everything is connected. You know, when you look at the temple, there's like the snakes are all, you know, wrapped around whatever, but it's not really a separate figures like the Parthenon. And so they really saw these things as just kind of being inevitable expressions of,
但那并不是真正的样子。这是一种相互关联的能量，他们将能量视为一种弥漫的东西，与自身处于紧张状态。有时你有必须相处才能创造世界的对立双胞胎，一切都是相互关联的。当你看着神庙时，蛇都缠绕在一起，但它不像帕台农神庙那样是独立的形象。所以他们真的把这些东西视为某种不可避免的表达，
of, of, um, you know, uh, just kind of universal principles. And when the Spanish are like, you know,
某种普遍原则。当西班牙人说，去打破你们的神，去粉碎这些东西时，他们只是感到困惑。他们说，如果你想打破这些石头，你可以打破，但神已经死了。就像他们，
go ahead and break your gods, you know, smash these things that they're just kind of confused. And they're like, well, we can break these rocks if you want, but the gods are dead. Like they,
月亮女神已经被肢解了，你知道，这些东西只是宇宙运作方式的一部分，当时存在这种困惑，而西班牙人把阿兹特克人的建筑视为偶像，他们无法理解，阿兹特克人更多地将其视为他们世界观的代表，这更难打破。
the, the moon goddess has already been, uh, dismembered you know like these these things are are just part of uh part of the way that the universe works and there was this confusion you know whereas the spanish saw you know a lot of the uh architecture in the and and the as like idols in a way that you know they couldn't understand you know the aztecs saw that more as um just a representation of their worldview, you know, which is harder to break.
嗯，我的意思是，这更像是一种心理信仰，我们承认这些神，无论是希腊、阿兹特克、玛雅、奥尔梅克还是托尔特克，都是原型原则、意识的品质和风格，是次要表现出来的潜能。我的意思是，因此它们出现在古代神庙、神话和我们的梦中，对吧？它们在那里以有意义的方式补偿和纠正原本有限的自我意识，
Well, I mean, but rather a psychological faith in what we recognize as these gods, the ancient gods, whether they're Greek or Aztec or Mayan or Olmec, Toltec, as archetypal principles, qualities and styles of consciousness, potentials within that manifest secondarily. I mean, hence their images on the ancient temples and in the mythologies and in our dreams, right? They're there to compensate and correct in a meaningful way the otherwise limited ego consciousness,
这可能是压抑的，因为它太有限了。我的意思是，所以压抑那种世界观，就像荣格所说的，神现在在疾病中显现，对吧？在疾病中，你知道，我觉得……我们不理解且无法控制的事情。我们已经填补了地图上的空白，以至于我们觉得除了试管、粒子物理学或其他什么之外，我们无法解释的事情，
which can be oppressive because it is so limited. I mean, so to repress that kind of worldview, it was going, like Jung said, the gods manifest now in disease, right? In diseases, you know, and I feel... The things that we don't understand and don't have power over. You know, we've filled in the blank edges of the map so much that the only things that we feel like we can't explain with a test tube or, you know, particle physics or something
就是那些正在杀死我们且我们无法阻止的事情。所以这就是我们宗教的程度，我的意思是，我认为你看到了那种原型能量随着像新冠疫情这样的事情爆发出来，其中一些政治反应几乎就像精神分裂症，只是无意识原型的爆发，因为人们不明白发生了什么。而且因为我们历史上否认了阴影，我的意思是，我记得新冠疫情爆发时，就像我们所有人一样，但我记得那是在澳大利亚丛林大火中数百万动物死亡之后。
are the things that are killing us that we can't stop. So that was the extent of our religion, which I mean, I think you see that archetypal energy coming out with something like COVID, where, you know, some of the political reactions are almost like schizophrenia, you know, just this bursting of unconscious, you know, archetypes, because people don't understand what's happening. And because we historically have denied the shadow, you know, I mean, to me, I remember when COVID broke out, like all of us do, but I remember that that was on the heels of how many millions of animals that had died in the Australian bushfires.
是的。对我来说，我感到不寒而栗，感到恐惧。我想，我们将因为那个经历什么样的反响？我的意思是，当然，因为瘟疫，为什么我们不会呢？我们表现得好像我们没有联系。这就是我们科学如此还原论的地方。现在是时候像飞跃一样了，因为我们从科学中学到了很多。现在我们必须连接它们。现在我们必须将古老的与新的结合起来，这样我们就不会真正成功地毁灭自己，这样人类也许能度过这个集体成年礼，正如理查德·塔纳斯（Richard Tarnas）所称的那样。而且，
Yeah. To me, I wondered, I thought, I was chilled, I mean, horrified. And I thought, what kind of repercussion are we going to experience as a result of that, you know? And well, I mean, of course, I mean, because a plague, you know, why wouldn't we? You know, we act as if we're not connected. That's where that limited, you know, that's where our science has been so reductive. And it's time for like a leap because we've learned so much from our sciences. Now we have to connect them. Now we have to, you know, join the ancient with the new so that we don't really successfully destroy ourselves so that maybe humanity can make it through this collective rite of passage, you know, as Richard Tarnas calls it. And there's,
对我来说，真的没有其他看待它的方式了。在任何成年礼中，都有死亡和重生的希望。那种重生不是保证的。这才是让它变得真实的原因，对吧？在我们放开旧事物之前，我们不能一只脚踏入下一件事。你必须看着它消失，也许并没有。
to me, there's really no other way to look at it. You know, in any rite of passage, there is a death and a hope of a rebirth. That rebirth isn't guaranteed. That's what makes it real, right? And we can't really have one foot in the next thing before we let go of the old thing. You know, you kind of have to watch it go away, and maybe there isn't.
嗯，是的，也不是，Joel，因为我认为这就是想象力发挥作用的地方。佛教学者、现年90多岁的活动家乔安娜·梅西（Joanna Macy）说，我们无法孕育出我们内心尚未想象出的东西。在心中消亡。那是那个词。那更多是一种直觉，而不是基于智力自我的知识。它更多地与感觉和想象力有关。
Well, yes and no, Joel, because one of the things that, I think this is where imagination comes in. One of the things that the Buddhist scholar, now in her 90s, activist Joanna Macy says is that we cannot give birth to what we have not first imagined in our hearts. Perished in our hearts. That's the word. That's more of an intuition, you know, than an intellectual ego-based knowledge. It's more, yeah, and it has more to do with, yeah, feeling and imagination.
现在，记住爱因斯坦说过想象力比知识更重要。14世纪的炼金术士马丁·鲁兰（Martin Ruhland）说，想象力是人身上的星星，是人身上的天星。帕拉塞尔苏斯称它为“人身上的太阳”。法国哲学家和伊斯兰学者亨利·科尔宾（Henri Corbin）说，心脏是想象力的种子，心脏用图像说话。所以我们能够首先想象出那是什么，我认为这是在失去魔力的世界中最大的挑战。科尔宾谈到了“想象世界”（Mundus Imaginalis），对吧？想象的，不是虚构的。他创造了“imaginal”这个词来区分“imaginal”和“imaginary”，
Now, remember that Einstein said imagination was more important than knowledge. The 14th century alchemist Martin Ruhland said that imagination is the star in man, the celestial star in man. Paracelsus called it the sun in man. And French philosopher and Islamic scholar Henri Corbin said that the heart is the seed of the imagination, and the heart speaks in images and so for us to be able to imagine first what it is that's i think that's the biggest challenge of all in a disenchanted world you know it's not as the um corbin talked about the the mundusinalis, right? The imaginal world. Imaginal, not imaginary. He coined the term imaginal to distinguish between imaginal and imaginary,
我们认为后者更像是幻想。逃避现实。是的，逃避现实。说得好。所以想象力，用源于心脏的想象力去引导，那是不同的，而且不容易。我的意思是，它在群体中最好，它在群体中有一种灵魂的同行评审，因为我经常告诉病人的一件事是，你的创伤和直觉来自
which we consider more like fantasy. Escapism. Yes, escapism. Well put. So the imagination to lead forth with the imagination that arises from the heart that's different and it's and it's not easy i mean and it's best in groups it's best it's harder well and there's some sort of uh uh you know peer review of the soul that happens in a group because you know one of the things i tell patients a lot is that your trauma and your intuition come
大脑的同一部分，直到你处理了创伤，你怎么知道你真正感受到并采取行动的是什么？它感觉就像某种无意识的强迫，你知道，就像，这家伙在谷歌上有四颗星，每个人都说他是个好人，但我有一种感觉，这不对劲，或者我害怕穿红毛衣的男人？你不知道。所以虽然有很多痛苦，但我认为想象力的问题之一是我们把阴影投射到其中，而当你真正处于想象的体验中时，它是在那之下的。
from the same part of the brain until you deal with the the trauma how do you know what it is that you're really feeling and acting on it it feels like this kind of unconscious compulsion you know like uh you know does this guy have four stars on google and everybody says he's he's a good guy but something I'm just getting a feeling that this is not right or am I afraid of men in red sweaters like you don't know and so while there's so much pain um you know i think one of the problems with the imaginary is that we project kind of our shadow into it whereas when you're really in the experience of the imaginal it's kind of beneath that it's kind of what it's kind of beneath it's beneath that oh i see yeah it's and and i think that's you're talking about hellman but i think that's what hellman was looking for part of his
它是在那之下的，哦，我明白了。我认为那是你在谈论希尔曼（Hillman），但我认为那是希尔曼在寻找的东西。他离开研究所时的部分挫折感是他厌倦了分析。他想要直接的体验。我认为他想要的直接体验比他认为他所来自的一神论信仰（如犹太教或基督教）所能提供的要多。那正是他的观点，我们拥有多神论的心理。那是他的东西。这不是一种回归或回到希腊宗教的愿望，而是对多神论心理的认可。荣格说，当大地被去心理化时，也就是去灵魂化，换句话说，我们想象我们现在如此复杂。我们远超那些想象岩石有生命、能说话的古代宗教。
frustration with the institutes when he leaves is he was tired of analysis. He wanted direct experience. I think he wanted more direct experience than he thought that a monotheistic faith like Judaism that he was coming from or Christianity could have. That precisely was his point, was that we have a polytheistic psyche. That was his thing. It wasn't a reversion or a desire to return to that, to the Greek religion, but to recognition of a polytheistic psyche. Jung, he said when the earth was de-psychized, right? So de-tholed, in other words, that what we did, we imagined that somehow we were so sophisticated now. We were way beyond these ancient religions that imagined that a rock had life or that it could speak or anything.
然而，我们所做的是将我们的恶魔、阴影和黑暗投射到其他人身上。是的，因为他们是唯一还活着的。与世界没有对话，而你通过人际关系与世界进行对话。那是危险的。就是这样。当我们考虑到宗教裁判所从欧洲扩展到美洲所犯下的暴行时。
And yet, so what we did was project our demons and our shadows and our darknesses onto other people. Yeah, because they were the only thing left alive. There was no conversation with the world, and you have your conversation through the world interpersonally. That's dangerous. That's it. And when we consider the atrocities committed by the Inquisition that expanded from Europe to the Americas.
人类历史上最糟糕的酷刑装置是以基督的名义创造的。这太惊人了。那些害怕自己性欲和女性的厌女祭司。所以他们能够将邪恶向外投射，创造出最可怕的酷刑装置，并在那个过程中得到净化。那种变态和残暴的程度令人难以置信。
The worst torture devices in human history were created in the name of Christ. It's phenomenal. The misogynist priesthood that were afraid of their own sexuality and women. And so they were able to project the evil outwards and create the most hideous torture devices and become purged in that process. The level of perversion and brutality is mind boggling.
然而，这就是我们对任何事物所做的。而古代民族，每当有灵魂的世界再次对他们说话时，他们就被强加给他们的恐惧所创伤，以至于他们会将其作为阴影、作为邪恶向外投射。哦，不，我们不能听那个。你知道，它变成了邪恶。任何除了三位一体和人类之外有灵魂的东西都被认为是邪恶的。我的意思是，这太还原论了。而且希尔曼或任何人会在某个时刻说“这行不通”也就不足为奇了。一神论，那不是心理的结构方式。我们是多神论结构的。所以我们有很多部分。当你试图把它变成一个整体时，它效果并不好。
And yet that is what we've done to anything. And the ancient peoples, whenever the ensouled world spoke to them again, they were so traumatized by the fear imposed upon them that they then would project it outwardly as shadow, as evil. Oh, no, we can't listen to that. You know,y became evil. Anything that was in sold other than the Trinity and human beings that was considered evil. I mean, that's incredibly reductionist. I mean, and it would be no wonder that Hillman or anybody would at a certain point go, yeah, this isn't working. The monotheism, that's not how the psyche is structured. We are polytheistically structured. So there's a lot of parts of us. And when you try and make it a monolith, how the psyche is structured. We are polytheistically structured. So there's a lot of parts of us. And when you try and make it a monolith, it doesn't work as well.
我的意思是，仅仅从人际关系上来说。我认为深度心理学比做认知或基于边界的咨询稍微有效一点的原因是，从那里开始而不是从情感开始，从智力开始，当你理解了你自己的部分时，你就理解了其他人的部分。所以在感恩节，我不必在否认爷爷到底是谁并说他是最好的人，或者取消他并引起大场面之间做选择。我可以有点像，你知道，
I mean, just interpersonally. I mean, I think one of the reasons why depth psychology is a little bit more effective than doing, you know, cognitive or boundaries-based counseling, starting there instead of with the emotional, start with the intellectual is, you know, when you do, when you understand the parts of yourself, you understand the parts of other people. So at Thanksgiving, I, I don't have to decide between, you know, denying who granddad really is and saying, well, he's the best guy ever or canceling him and causing a big scene. I can kind of be like, you know,
这是我所爱之人的未实现潜能。这很悲伤。没能实现这一点是一场悲剧。此外，这些是我喜欢的他的部分。当人们不那么单一时，我们个人更容易相处，当社会和宗教不那么单一时，我们通常更温和，我们使用的“铁娘子”也更少。说得好，甚至可能战争也更少。所以有很多需要考虑的，这是脆弱性。如果你需要，就像基督教在最糟糕的阶段，就像你谈到的，它需要完美。如果它需要完美，那么其他一切都被投射到外面。所以，如果我被教导要憎恨脆弱性，
this is the unrealized potential of this person who I love. And it's very sad. It's a tragedy to don't actualize that. Also, these are the parts of him that I like and when people are less monolithic just individually we're a little bit easier to be around and when society and religion is a little bit less monolithic we uh are usually a little bit general uh you know uh we're gentler and there are less you know iron maidens that we're using to try and find well put and and and maybe even less wars you know yeah so there's there's there's so much to consider you know it's vulnerability if you need like where where christianity and its worst phases um like you're talking about uh is where it needs to be perfect and if it needs to be perfect. And if it needs to be perfect, then everything else is projected outside. Um, and so like, if, if I am, um, if I'm, if I'm raised to hate vulnerability,
不完美，我必须否认我自己的并压抑它，那么我就会投射它并攻击它。所以发生的事情是，任何你看到受伤的人，那都是好的，因为我总是站在施虐者一边。每当有人伤害别人时，我站在施虐者一边，而受害者是坏的。然后无论你的神学、政治或神话是什么，它都是次要的。情感反应是第一位的，那种原型反应。然后第二位，你会说，哦，自由市场做了这件事，或者他们不是基督徒，你以后会编造一个理由。但当你觉得你是完美的时候，你压抑你的脆弱性，你需要投射那种脆弱性并在外部攻击它。
you know, imperfection, and I have to disown my own and repress it, then I'm going to project it and attack it. So what happens there is anybody who you see who is hurting, well, that is good because all I'm always going to side with the abuser in every case. And anytime anyone's hurting somebody, I'm on the side of the person who's doing the hurting and the person who is getting hurt is bad. And then whatever your theology or politics or mythology is, it's secondary to that. The emotional reaction is first, that archetypal reaction. And then second, you're like, oh, well, the free market did it or you know well they aren't christian you invent a reason later you know but the need when you feel like you are perfect um and you're repressing your vulnerability is to project that vulnerability and attack it externally
那种完美的想法，难道不是吗？我认为这真的很关键，它与深度心理学或荣格深度心理学的目标非常不同。因为，我的意思是，目标不是完美，而是完整。我们是光明与黑暗。我们是有意识和无意识的。古代的神既有创造力也有破坏力。那只是完整的形象。你真的不想看约柜。一个人承受不了那么多。
that that whole idea of perfection is it isn't it i mean i think that's really key and it's so different let's say than the aim of depth psychology or the Jungian depth psychology. Because, I mean, where the aim isn't perfection, but wholeness. You know, we are light and dark. We are conscious and unconscious. You know, the ancient gods of old were creative and destructive. That's just an image of wholeness. You don't really want to look in the Ark of the Covenant. It's too much for one person to hold.
嗯，原型，当你观察神时会发生什么？我的意思是，有疯狂，或者随之而来的死亡，对吧？所以那种完美的观念，我认为确实以一种残酷和片面的方式阻碍了文化。我是在天主教环境下长大的，那种东西会伴随你。我记得那种对完美的追求。我想，不，不，不，我们是人类。
Well, archetypal, what happens when you view the God? I mean, there's, you know, an insanity, right? A madness or death that ensues, right? I mean, so that whole notion, again, of perfection, I think has really stilted the culture in such a sort of a brutal and one-sided way. I mean, I grew up Catholic and dang, you know, that kind of stuff stays with you. You know, and I remember that striving for perfection. And I think, no, no, no, we're human.
我们是光明与黑暗。我们是脆弱与强大的。天主教似乎变得更加根深蒂固和稳定，是在人们，通常在南美洲，与个别圣徒有更多关系的地方。就是这样。你对神圣有更多的容器，而那些变成西班牙宗教裁判所的地方往往会烧毁一切。圣徒们都能保持神性的一面。我觉得，天生如此，在拉丁美洲生活了15年后，墨西哥的圣徒日全年都在庆祝。我的意思是，你可以看到那里有多神论的心理。
You know, we are light and dark. We are, you know, vulnerable and strong, you know. And where Catholicism seems to have gotten more entrenched and stabilized is where the people, usually in South America, people have more of a relationship with individual saints. Well, that's it. You have more of a container for the divine, whereas the places where it becomes the Spanish Inquisition tend to burn out. The saints are all able to hold an aspect of divinity. And I feel that, I mean, innately, when you're having lived in Latin America for 15 years, the saints' days in Mexico are celebrated year-round. I mean, you can see that there is the polytheistic psyche.
虽然他们非常天主教，但它仍然非常基督教。而且仍然对魔鬼有极大的恐惧。所以，当我住在米却肯州时，它确实在整个墨西哥，特别是在农村地区，这些古老的圣经故事被演绎出来。我住在一个制作面具的村庄外面，天哪，这太不可思议了，比如圣乔治与龙搏斗，或者魔鬼与大天使米迦勒搏斗。我的意思是，戴着面具和穿着布料。随着心理的需要，他们创造了新的圣徒，天主教教会甚至可能不批准，比如在墨西哥的许多地区，死亡作为圣徒，像贩毒暴力。是的，确实。
And while they're very, you know, Catholic, well, it's still very Christian. And there's still the great fear of the devil. It's so, when I lived in Michoacán, well, I mean, it's still very christian yeah and there's still the great fear of the devil it's it's so when i lived in michoacan well i mean it's really throughout mexico as particularly in the rural areas these ancient biblical stories are enacted you know where i was i lived right outside of a mass making village and oh my god mean, it's like they would be incredible, you know, St. George fighting the dragons or, you know, the devils fighting Michael the archangel. I mean, but in masks and fabrics. And as the psyche needs it, they create new saints that the Catholic Church may not even approve of, like death as a saint in a lot of regions of Mexico, like hotels and drug violence. Yes, indeed.
我去教堂漏掉了一个。我们需要。不。所以我想回到建筑的想法。大卫·卡拉斯科（David Carrasco）是一位中美洲学者，也是哈佛神学院和哈佛人类学的学术教授。他写了很多关于中美洲和古代宗教的文章。他还编辑了伯纳尔·迪亚斯·德尔·卡斯蒂略（Bernal Díaz del Castillo）的《新西班牙征服史》。而伯纳尔·迪亚斯·德尔·卡斯蒂略，
I go to the church left drug violence. Yes, indeed. I go to the church left one out. We need to. No. So I wanted to go back to the idea of architecture. You know, in David Carrasco, who is a Mesoamerican scholar and academic professor in both the Harvard Divinity School and anthropology at Harvard. He's written a lot on Mesoamerica and the ancient religions. He also edited Bernal Díaz del Castillo's History of New Spain. And Bernal Díaz del Castillo,
对于不知道的读者，他是15世纪的编年史家之一，也是一名士兵，对吧？所以显然一切都是为国王写的。他们试图推销他们的战争和他们所做的任何事情。卡拉斯科回去做的是，他看了特诺奇蒂特兰的古地图，那是阿兹特克的首都，对吧？他注意到它是被创造的，它是被划分的。有中心和四个基本点。整个城市就是基于此。现在，玛雅人也是，他们的建筑，他们的金字塔，
for the readers who don't know, so he was one of the, in the 15th century, he was one of the chroniclers, Spanish chroniclers, as well as a soldier, right? So obviously everything is written for the king. They're trying to sell their, you know, their wars and whatever they're doing. And when, what he, what Carrasco went back and did is he looked at the map, the ancient map of Tenochtitlan, which is the capital of, the Aztec capital, right? And what he noted was that it was created in, it was divided. There was the center and the four cardinal points. That's how the entire city was based. Now, the Mayans also, their architecture, their pyramids,
他们的城邦，像阿兹特克人一样，是根据宇宙、根据星星放置的，是对齐的，对吧？四个基本点和中心被认为是神圣的几何，将13个天界和9个冥界与中间世界（我们，地球）统一起来，对吧？作为神圣的几何，它允许神在任何时候渗透到地球和所有生物中。它允许人类沉浸在神话时间中。是的。我想这就是马菲在谈论他的书中的Teot能量时所说的。
their city-states, like the Aztecs, were placed according to the cosmos, according to the stars, in alignment with, right? And the four cardinal points and the center was considered the sacred geometry that united the 13 celestial realms and the nine underworld realms with the middle world, which was us, the earth, right? And that, as a sacred geometry, it allowed humans to, the gods to interpenetrate the earth and all living beings at all times. And it allowed the humans to become sort of immersed in a mythical time. Yeah. I think that's what Maffey is talking about when he's talking about the energy of Teot in his book.
他们的城邦，就像阿兹特克人一样，是根据宇宙和星辰的位置来布局的，与四个基本方位对齐，对吧？中心被视为神圣的几何结构，将13个天界和9个冥界与中间的世界——也就是我们所在的地球——连接起来，对吧？作为一种神圣的几何结构，它使得神灵能够时刻渗透到地球和所有生物之中。它也让人们能够沉浸在一种神话般的时间里。是的，我想这就是马菲在他的书中谈论Teot能量时所指的意思。
Oh, okay. You're always channeling this energy that's moving back and forth between worlds that looks very similar to like a metaphysics or something so like a a particle physics or something that we would have now you know sort of understood identity and divinity as a particle and a wave i need i need to i need to what's the name of that book again it's called aztec philosophy but aztec metaphysics might have been a better idea. All right, great. So one of the things that Carrasco mentions is one of the Aztec wise men once commented that if Tenochtitlan were to fall, if the capital were to fall, the sky would collapse. Now, if we interchange the word sky with consciousness,
哦，好的。你总是引导这种在世界之间来回流动的能量，这看起来非常类似于某种形而上学，或者像我们现在所理解的粒子物理学之类的东西，即把身份和神性理解为粒子和波。我需要，我需要，我需要……那本书叫什么名字来着？它叫《阿兹特克哲学》，但《阿兹特克形而上学》可能是一个更好的主意。好的，太棒了。卡拉斯科（Carrasco）提到的其中一件事是，一位阿兹特克智者曾评论说，如果特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）陷落，如果首都陷落，天空就会崩塌。现在，如果我们把“天空”这个词换成“意识”，
we could say that it did collapse. The consciousness of humanity did collapse, you know, and we fell into kind of a darkness the last 500 years where we imagine ourselves as orphans floating around in the universe, right? Skin encapsulated egos, which, of course, served industrial revolution and the corporate fantasy, as Hellman called it. I mean, so, you know, it's served a purpose, you know, and Marx just, you know, right to this point in history where we're brought to our knees, you know, and yet it continues, you know, convulsing and, you know, madically trying to get the last, you know, vestiges of whatever needs to be extracted.
我们可以说它确实崩塌了。人类的意识确实崩塌了，你知道，在过去的500年里，我们陷入了一种黑暗，我们把自己想象成漂浮在宇宙中的孤儿，对吧？皮肤包裹的自我，这当然服务于工业革命和赫尔曼（Hellman）所说的企业幻想。我的意思是，所以，你知道，它达到了一个目的，你知道，马克思只是，你知道，一直到历史的这一点，我们被逼得跪下，你知道，然而它还在继续，你知道，抽搐着，你知道，疯狂地试图获取任何需要被提取的东西的最后残余。
It's short-sighted by its nature. It can't be concerned with timeless things because that is obviously a longer term. Because it goes against industrial goals. Progress, what we call progress. Why go up? To me, that idea of creating, and I listened to that last podcast of yours, which I thought was fascinating. But if we're considering how, you know, how to rebuild, you know, how to reimagine the earth and recreate it, you know how what does it look like you know how do we how do we realign ourselves with the stars in in cities and in metropolis i mean to me i always i used to have a program uh
它本质上是短视的。它不可能关心永恒的事物，因为那显然是更长期的。因为它违背了工业目标。进步，我们所说的进步。为什么要向上？对我来说，那种创造的想法，我听了你上一期的播客，我觉得非常迷人。但如果我们正在考虑如何，你知道，如何重建，你知道，如何重新构想地球并重新创造它，你知道，它看起来是什么样子的，你知道，我们如何，我们如何与城市和大都市中的星星重新对齐？我的意思是，对我来说，我总是，我过去有一个项目，呃
uh one of my uh projects called imagine you know imagining a new world into being because it's like peace you know if you look up peace in any dictionary, you'll see that it's the absence of war. And if that's the case, then it's not likely we'll ever have it. Because if we can't imagine it, if we don't know what it looks like, what it feels like, then, well, again, it's not likely we'll ever have it. What does it look like? What does a city that's aligned with the cosmos look like? You can't even see the stars in a city. It's too bright.
呃，我的一个项目叫“想象”，你知道，想象一个新世界诞生，因为这就像和平，你知道，如果你在任何字典里查“和平”，你会看到它是战争的缺失。如果是这样的话，那么我们很可能永远不会拥有它。因为如果我们无法想象它，如果我们不知道它看起来是什么样子，感觉是什么样子，那么，好吧，再说一次，我们很可能永远不会拥有它。它看起来是什么样子的？一个与宇宙对齐的城市看起来是什么样子的？你在城市里甚至看不到星星。太亮了。
You've got to go out. That's it. I live in LA. For me, as someone that has a love affair with the stars, I feel that absence. The Aztecs' solution, I think, was the calendar of festivals. I mean, those festivals are commemorating celestial events and dates. There it is.
你必须走出去。就是这样。我住在洛杉矶。对我来说，作为一个与星星有恋情的人，我感受到了那种缺失。我认为阿兹特克人的解决方案是节日历法。我的意思是，那些节日是为了纪念天体事件和日期。就是这样。
There's that alignment with the cosmos. That's the point. And that, to me, as we reimagine, we have to reconsider how cities are built. You know, that temino space, right? I mean, because Timino space, right? I mean, cause where are a plaza?
这就是与宇宙的对齐。重点就在这里。对我来说，当我们重新构想时，我们必须重新考虑城市是如何建造的。你知道，那个“特米诺”（temino）空间，对吧？我的意思是，因为特米诺空间，对吧？我的意思是，因为广场在哪里？
Even go back to Greek structure, but they had the hearths, Hestia, there were hearths, you know, every place had their plazas with their central hearths where storytelling was happening, you know, where the bars. We still have the ripples of that. Like now if you're having an interior designer come to your house and you drag your couch in front of your fireplace you know something in us says that's not right but we're not sitting there going like oh the roman penates the hearth fires the ancestors and we must keep it burning at all times or else it doesn't like that isn't something that we intellectually are doing
甚至回到希腊结构，但他们有炉膛，赫斯提亚（Hestia），有炉膛，你知道，每个地方都有他们的广场，有中央炉膛，故事就在那里发生，你知道，酒吧在哪里。我们仍然有那些涟漪。就像现在，如果你让室内设计师来你家，你把沙发拖到壁炉前，你知道我们内心有什么东西说那是不对的，但我们并没有坐在那里说，哦，罗马的佩纳特斯（Penates），炉火，祖先，我们必须时刻保持它燃烧，否则它不喜欢……那不是我们在智力上正在做的事情
anymore yet there is still this design language of do not put something in front of your fireplace because it is it has to be able to radiate out you know even if it's something that is not going to be affected by heat or something you're designing around that as a central point you know the caveman television or whatever which goes back to the you know greek hastia or the roman penates you know ancestral altars that are burning all the time there you you go. There you go. So, I mean, so that's it. How do we incorporate that wisdom into, let's say, interior design, exterior design, architecture? How do we begin to create those kind of, well, again, connections with the cosmos that we've been cut off from?
了，但仍然存在这种设计语言：不要把东西放在壁炉前，因为它必须能够向外辐射，你知道，即使它是不受热影响的东西，你也是围绕那个中心点进行设计的，你知道，穴居人的电视机什么的，这可以追溯到，你知道，希腊的赫斯提亚或罗马的佩纳特斯，你知道，时刻燃烧的祖先祭坛，这就对了。这就对了。所以，我的意思是，就是这样。我们如何将这种智慧融入到，比方说，室内设计、外部设计、建筑中？我们如何开始创造那种，好吧，再说一次，我们与之隔绝的与宇宙的联系？
How do we re-enchant our earth? We pulled Psyche out of it and just into us and where the world is dead and we're alive and i don't know if you've ever um he's probably had a pretty negative effect on the world but one of the guys who does like he basically kind of did the big last wave of american advertising it's like a french clinical psychologist but he figured out how to sell these products to americans and sargento cheese was like really big in france and so they played the ads here and um you know the the cheese was like um it may be interesting to have him on the podcast if he'd return an email but you know it was like hands touching it and warm light and people blowing the dust off the cheese and the bacterial you know crust and
我们如何重新赋予地球魔力？我们把灵魂（Psyche）从它里面拉出来，只拉进我们自己体内，世界是死的，而我们是活的。我不知道你是否曾经……他可能对世界产生了相当负面的影响，但其中一个做……他基本上完成了美国广告的最后一大浪潮，他是一位法国临床心理学家，但他弄清楚了如何向美国人销售这些产品。萨根托（Sargento）奶酪在法国非常大，所以他们在这里播放了广告，嗯，你知道，奶酪就像……如果他能回复邮件，让他上播客可能会很有趣，但你知道，就像手触摸它，温暖的光，人们吹掉奶酪上的灰尘和细菌，你知道，外壳和
all this and they played it in america nobody wanted it and they went to him and he was like no in america it's dead you want a relationship with the cheese that it's part of you in the community they want it in a body bag and he invented a zippable bag that all cheese has now sergento was the first company to do that and it was his design because he said in america nothing is alive everything is dead you just want to be able to put the cheese in a body bag was the line. And he also did the first ad for the first Hummer. It's a big, scary car going through the town. And it's going over rocks in the city.
所有这些，他们在美国家播放，没人想要它。他们去找他，他说，不，在美国，它是死的。你想要一种与奶酪的关系，它是你和社区的一部分。他们想要它装在尸袋里。他发明了一种现在所有奶酪都有的可拉链袋，萨根托是第一家这样做的公司，这是他的设计，因为他说在美国，什么都没有生命，一切都是死的，你只是想把奶酪放进尸袋里，这就是那句台词。他还为第一辆悍马做了第一个广告。那是一辆又大又吓人的车穿过城镇。它在城市里碾过岩石。
And it goes through the city. And it looks real intimidating. And the window rolls down. And there's a teeny, tiny blonde girl in it. And he said, know the american man he knows he's tiny and feminine and weak but he needs a big car to protect you know his i mean and but like you know you can't say what the guy said because you don't want that associated with the brand but you know he's he wrote all these ads you know you know those things that brings me back to
它穿过城市。看起来真的很吓人。窗户摇下来了。里面有一个娇小的金发女孩。他说，了解美国男人，他知道自己很渺小、女性化且软弱，但他需要一辆大车来保护，你知道他的……我的意思是，但是就像，你知道，你不能说那个人说了什么，因为你不想让它与品牌联系在一起，但你知道，他写了所有这些广告，你知道，你知道那些事情，这让我想起了
one of the things that jung said about the world of advertising and media. He likened them to the dark magicians of the Renaissance. But it's not a good myth. Well, that's it. It's magic that serves the corporate agenda and has spun the worldview that we are living. Hijacking the religious impulse. There it is. You don't have to be an artist.
荣格（Jung）关于广告和媒体世界所说的一件事。他把他们比作文艺复兴时期的黑暗魔法师。但这不是一个好的神话。好吧，就是这样。这是服务于企业议程的魔法，并编织了我们所生活的世界观。劫持了宗教冲动。就是这样。你不必成为一名艺术家。
If you buy an Apple computer, you are an artist. You don't have to have a new way of life if you walk into a Starbucks. You just get to. That's well put. Hijacking, say that again, hijacking. Hijacking the religious impulse. One of the things I use with patients a lot is that you know we all have this transcendent function and if you think you're an enlightened atheist or the existential whatever you know and we're not saying you have to belong to organized religion or believe
如果你买了一台苹果电脑，你就是一名艺术家。如果你走进星巴克，你不必拥有新的生活方式。你只是得到它。说得好。劫持，再说一遍，劫持。劫持宗教冲动。我经常对病人使用的一件事是，你知道我们都有这种超越功能，如果你认为你是一个开明的无神论者或存在主义者什么的，你知道，我们并不是说你必须属于有组织的宗教或相信
you know in a metaphysical you know supernatural anything but if you're not aware where religion is operating in your life then it's going to be operating unconsciously and that's where you start to project the religious impulse onto products or onto what I can buy at Best Buy or onto like an economic system. It's like, say what you want about free market or whatever, but it's not a religion, man. But again, I mean, there it is there. We see that, that, that we see the, you know, the dark wizards, right. The dark, the dark magicians of the Renaissance at work, you know,
你知道，形而上学的，你知道，超自然的任何东西，但如果你没有意识到宗教在你的生活中是如何运作的，那么它就会在潜意识中运作，这就是你开始将宗教冲动投射到产品上，或者投射到我在百思买（Best Buy）能买到的东西上，或者投射到某种经济系统上的地方。就像，随你怎么说自由市场什么的，但它不是一种宗教，伙计。但再说一次，我的意思是，它就在那里。我们看到了，那个，那个，我们看到了，你知道，黑暗巫师，对吧。文艺复兴时期的黑暗魔法师在工作，你知道，
because they know what they're doing. They understand it. They get it. I mean, the fact that this French advertiser was actually a psychologist, that's the whole point, you know. And one of the things about the Jungian and archetypal depth psychology is what they did was they joined, again, psyche with logos, psychology. You know, they created that. I mean, of course, let's say the pioneer freud did too but i
因为他们知道自己在做什么。他们理解它。他们明白了。我的意思是，这个法国广告商实际上是一位心理学家，这才是重点，你知道。关于荣格和原型深度心理学的一件事是，他们所做的是，他们再次将灵魂（psyche）与逻辑（logos）结合起来，心理学。你知道，他们创造了那个。我的意思是，当然，弗洛伊德（Freud）这位先驱也做了，但我
mean you just took it further right psyche and logic i mean that's a fight in psychology that goes back forever that's still not solved you know cognitive therapist you know post 80s mainstream therapy wants it to be cbt you're only what you do your only behavior if you can't see it taste it touch it count it it's not real and then you know, there's kind of the more navel gazing, mystical, you know, Jungian emotion focused stuff of you are only what you feel. Who really cares about what's real? Quit your job, sell your shoes, become a Buddhist. And, you know, we need both of them, but we really we prefer one pretty strongly.
我的意思是，你只是把它推得更远了，对吧？灵魂和逻辑，我的意思是，那是心理学中一场永无止境的争论，至今仍未解决，你知道，认知治疗师，你知道，80年代后的主流治疗想要它是CBT（认知行为疗法），你只是你的行为，如果你看不见它、尝不到它、摸不到它、数不到它，它就不是真实的。然后，你知道，还有那种更沉思的、神秘的、你知道，荣格的以情感为中心的那些东西，你只是你的感受。谁真正在乎什么是真实的？辞掉工作，卖掉鞋子，成为一名佛教徒。而且，你知道，我们需要这两者，但我们确实，我们非常强烈地偏爱其中一个。
And, you know, I think a lot of, you know, good therapy is about the integration of that, which I think I mean, this is kind of going to the woods. But I think one of the only places where Jung is put better by another writer, like he never is able to articulate what he's trying to say, as well as another author puts him as Edinger. You know, and Edinger says, you go an archetype. You know, the ego does not want to be in the same head as the subconscious mystical self. You know, these two parts of self are at odds um you know i think that's underneath a lot of the tensions of the opposites that yun talks about well i mean and and if we look at that as a spectrum ego to the self self with a capital s meaning you know the the the god the the personal god image right i
而且，你知道，我认为很多，你知道，好的治疗是关于两者的整合，我认为，我的意思是，这有点像走进森林。但我认为荣格被另一位作家写得更好的地方之一，就像他从未能像另一位作者埃丁格（Edinger）那样清楚地表达他想说的话。你知道，埃丁格说，你有一个原型。你知道，自我不想和潜意识的神秘自我待在同一个脑袋里。你知道，这两个自我部分是矛盾的，嗯，你知道，我认为这在荣格谈论的许多对立面的紧张关系之下，好吧，我的意思是，如果我们把它看作一个从自我到自我的光谱，大写的“自我”（Self），意思是，你知道，上帝，那个个人的上帝形象，对吧，我
mean it's something that we're always you know it's something that we're always, you know, it's something that we're aiming towards and yet, you know, It's not a destination. It's a process. And it's always hitting a moving target. So if you meet the therapist that says, Oh, I've dealt with my shadow, I'm done. You don't know what that is in the room, man. I'll tell you where mine is. Like it's not done. I mean, that's the whole point, isn't it? These are...
我的意思是，这是我们一直在，你知道，这是我们一直在，你知道，这是我们正在瞄准的东西，然而，你知道，它不是一个目的地。它是一个过程。而且它总是在击中一个移动的目标。所以如果你遇到一个治疗师说，哦，我已经处理了我的阴影，我完成了。你不知道房间里那是什么，伙计。我会告诉你我的在哪里。就像它没有完成。我的意思是，这才是重点，不是吗？这些是……
You got to be careful with the Freudians. They think it's over. Well, that's it. Because, you know, in any given moment, every one of those gods, every one of those archetypes, every complex, every shadow has a life of its own. And yes, we can come to maybe maybe you know they lose their autonomy um to a degree what did what did hillman say he said you know we learn to carry a complex differently
你得小心弗洛伊德学派的人。他们认为一切都结束了。好吧，就是这样。因为，你知道，在任何给定的时刻，每一个神，每一个原型，每一个情结，每一个阴影都有它自己的生命。是的，我们也许可以，也许你知道，它们失去了自主权，嗯，在某种程度上，希尔曼（Hillman）说了什么？他说，你知道，我们学会了以不同的方式携带一个情结，
when we know that there's a god at the root of it you know i mean and that's the point is like because no we're never over it it's an ongoing project you know the healing process is an ongoing if you feel like you have dealt with an inevitability of psyche then you don't understand how it works you know um the inevitability of psyche yeah well i mean because because psyches i mean that's soul you know you don't never that's never done you know but with psyche and logos i mean it's giving language to the soul isn't it and so that's it and understanding is never done because it's so far beneath language you know it's and by the time you've described it you've cheapened it
当我们知道它的根源有一个神时，你知道，我的意思是，这就是重点，因为不，我们永远不会克服它，这是一个持续的项目，你知道，治愈过程是一个持续的过程，如果你觉得你已经处理了灵魂的必然性，那么你就不了解它是如何运作的，你知道，嗯，灵魂的必然性，是的，好吧，我的意思是，因为因为灵魂，我的意思是，那是灵魂（soul），你知道，你永远不会，那永远不会完成，你知道，但对于灵魂和逻辑，我的意思是，它是在给灵魂赋予语言，不是吗？所以就是这样，理解永远不会完成，因为它远在语言之下，你知道，它，当你描述它时，你已经贬低了它。
you know i think that's why a lot of the yungians leave in the 70s and 80s you know all these people leave the institutes when they've become so analytical and they're basically yungian literalists and you start to get you know arnie Mandel with process therapy and Cedrin Hellstone with voice dialogue and you know countless other people that left therapy to do workshops and you know these different things because they wanted direct experience and the institutes had become pure analysis forever that never ended um and and so you you saw that um and yeah that's what hillman i think was trying to articulate i mean that kind of drives hillman mad until he finds the red book you know at the end of his life he's not a well guy you know there's some clips um and it scares me because you know like i
你知道，我认为这就是为什么很多荣格派在70年代和80年代离开，你知道，当这些机构变得如此分析化，他们基本上是荣格字面主义者时，所有这些人都会离开，你开始得到，你知道，阿尼·曼德尔（Arnie Mandel）的流程治疗，塞德林·赫尔斯通（Cedrin Hellstone）的对话，你知道，无数其他人离开治疗去举办研讨会，你知道这些不同的事情，因为他们想要直接的体验，而这些机构变成了永无止境的纯粹分析，嗯，所以你看到了那个，嗯，是的，这就是我认为希尔曼试图表达的，我的意思是，那有点让希尔曼发疯，直到他在生命尽头找到《红书》（Red Book），你知道，他不是一个健康的人，你知道，有一些片段，嗯，这让我很害怕，因为你知道，就像我
yeah i see a lot of male jungians having gone insane by the end of their life, you know, and it's scary. You know, I want to, I want to be careful and I relate a lot of to what Hillman did, but I also see where he kind of loses the thread. But I think that that was what he was trying to articulate with archetypal
是的，我看到很多男性荣格派在生命尽头疯了，你知道，这很可怕。你知道，我想，我想小心一点，我与希尔曼所做的事情有很多共鸣，但我也看到了他有点失去线索的地方。但我认为这就是他试图用原型心理学表达的东西，
psychology that he could never quite say was that he wanted there to be this direct re-experiencing of these forces that he felt like no one else was paying attention to or even looking for anymore in therapy and psychology in therapy and psychology and i think what what to me because to me hillman you know because he did go back to you know unlike jung who who really worked hard to because he was such a mystic he worked so hard to be the empiricist scientist, right? Until he couldn't be. Well, and Hillman didn't have to do that so much.
他永远无法完全说出来的是，他希望能够直接重新体验这些力量，他觉得在治疗和心理学中，在治疗和心理学中，再也没有人关注或寻找这些力量了，我认为对我来说，因为对我来说，希尔曼，你知道，因为他确实回到了，你知道，不像荣格，他真的努力工作，因为他是一个神秘主义者，他非常努力地成为经验主义科学家，对吧？直到他无法做到为止。好吧，希尔曼不需要做那么多。
He went right into the romantics. And I love that about Hillman. To me, Hillman writes so much. What he writes is poetic, is poetry. Yeah, and he does become a cranky old man. And I love what he did in the 100, we've had 100 years of uh psychoanalysis right and and so so to me um what he emphasized was that it has to be taken to the streets which is what i think the podcast i mean to me that's what i aim for in my podcast
他直接进入了浪漫主义。我喜欢希尔曼的那一点。对我来说，希尔曼写了很多。他写的东西是诗意的，是诗歌。是的，他确实变成了一个脾气暴躁的老人。我喜欢他在100年里所做的事情，我们已经有了100年的精神分析，对吧，所以对我来说，嗯，他强调的是，它必须被带到街头，这就是我认为播客的意义，我的意思是，对我来说，这就是我在我的播客中追求的目标，
because what good is it if we're just you know preaching to the choir it does have to you know it's like we these concepts you know that that seek to re-enchant, reunite us with the unsold world, with the anima mundi. This is key. This is key as we move forward in this, you know, in this crucial Kairos moment, you know. Go ahead. Oh, no, please. Sorry. Well, I mean, to me, that's it. I just feel like, to me, I draw from, you know, from both, you know, the Jungian
因为如果我们只是，你知道，向唱诗班布道，那有什么用呢？它确实必须，你知道，就像我们这些概念，你知道，寻求重新赋予魔力，让我们与无灵魂的世界，与世界灵魂（anima mundi）重新团聚。这是关键。这是关键，当我们在这个，你知道，在这个关键的凯洛斯（Kairos）时刻前进时，你知道。请继续。哦，不，请。抱歉。好吧，我的意思是，对我来说，就是这样。我只是觉得，对我来说，我从，你知道，从两者中汲取，你知道，荣格派
and the archetypal, from the Mesoamerican, you know, from mythology in general, from poetry, from art, from beauty, from music, from voice, all of these things, you know, to where, that are the language of the soul. It is a conscious search for re-enchantment. I'm so sorry. Go ahead. That's right. I mean, as a ritual artist, that's my work. It's sort of a re-enchantment. I'd like to hear a little bit about the ritual art.
和原型派，从美洲原住民，你知道，从神话，从诗歌，从艺术，从美，从音乐，从声音，所有这些东西，你知道，到哪里，它们是灵魂的语言。这是一场有意识的重新赋予魔力的搜索。我很抱歉。请继续。没错。我的意思是，作为一名仪式艺术家，那是我的工作。这是一种重新赋予魔力。我想听听关于仪式艺术的一些事情。
I mean, that's kind of the focus of our podcast is like we're doing, we want to talk about cutting edge of brain-based medicine and, you know, how do you, how do you treat trauma with very modern, you know, approaches, but then also the depth psychology, very few people have a foot in either world. Generally half of our clinic or our ideology will piss off, you know, the guests, you know, they like this thing, not that thing. Um, because we're talking about brain spotting and QEG brain mapping over here, which i think are developing the neurology of the phenomenology that jung described and then the timeless you know depth psychology things which is why the podcast i mean you're
我的意思是，这有点像我们播客的重点，就像我们正在做的，我们想谈谈基于大脑的医学的前沿，你知道，你如何，你如何用非常现代的，你知道，方法治疗创伤，但还有深度心理学，很少有人在两个世界都有立足点。通常我们的诊所或我们的意识形态的一半会惹恼，你知道，客人，你知道，他们喜欢这个东西，而不是那个东西。嗯，因为我们在这里谈论大脑定位（brain spotting）和QEG大脑映射，我认为它们正在发展荣格所描述的现象学的神经学，然后是永恒的，你知道，深度心理学的东西，这就是为什么播客，我的意思是，你
talking about ritual art and all these different things that's why we have a psychology of music a psychology of screenwriting we talk to rock stars we talk to country musicians we talk to architects we talk to urban planners because all of these are how do you find the most, you know, you're always, you're never going to get there. But how do you chase this vision of what is so deeply human in a way that is so ancient that we are disconnected from it, you know, trying to find it. And when you really find it, it's more natural. It's more healthy. Well put. And it is, to me, when I think about my process as a ritual artist,
谈论仪式艺术和所有这些不同的东西，这就是为什么我们有音乐心理学，编剧心理学，我们和摇滚明星交谈，我们和乡村音乐家交谈，我们和建筑师交谈，我们和城市规划师交谈，因为所有这些都是，你如何找到最，你知道，你总是，你永远不会到达那里。但你如何追逐这种对什么是如此深刻的人性的愿景，以至于我们与它断开了联系，你知道，试图找到它。当你真正找到它时，它更自然。它更健康。说得好。而且，对我来说，当我想到我作为仪式艺术家的过程时，
what the Jungian and the archetypal depth psychology allowed me was a framework to understand the work that I did. Because as a ritual artist, my work has always come from mythology and dreams. You know know and the imagination um and giving them image in in ritual art itself we know from um the romanian philosopher as well as marie louise von franz um that whenever a space is consecrated. Now, by consecration, it means whether you're using Copal or Palo Santo or stage
荣格和原型深度心理学允许我的是一个理解我所做工作的框架。因为作为一名仪式艺术家，我的工作一直来自神话和梦境。你知道，和想象力，嗯，并在仪式艺术本身中赋予它们形象，我们从，嗯，罗马尼亚哲学家以及玛丽-路易丝·冯·弗朗茨（Marie-Louise von Franz）那里知道，每当一个空间被神圣化时。现在，通过神圣化，这意味着无论你是使用柯巴脂（Copal）还是圣木（Palo Santo）或鼠尾草
or what has been used. You're taking it out of chaos and making it order, as Gugliotti Mercer would say. And yeah, so you create what he called, what was actually called in
或者已经使用过的东西。你正在把它从混乱中带出来并使之有序，正如古格里奥蒂·默瑟（Gugliotti Mercer）所说。是的，所以你创造了他所说的，实际上在
ancient cultures, was a sacred zone of absolute reality that unites you with the first of all with mythic time of beginning so that you're re you know you can create anything from this space and then you you've you've invoked the four directions in the center so now you're in sacred geometry that that aligns you again, right, with the cosmic spheres and on the earth itself. And so from this space, that's where the, I mean, you could call ritual art active imagination. That's where every little piece when you create your altar, you recognize as in sold. Whether you're creating a mandala, and the mandala, you know, Jung always encourages his patients to make mandalas because they bring resolution to the conflict, right?
古代文化中被称为绝对现实的神圣区域，它首先将你与开端的神话时间统一起来，这样你就可以从这个空间创造任何东西，然后你已经调用了四个方向和中心，所以现在你处于神圣几何中，这再次使你与宇宙球体和地球本身对齐。所以从这个空间，那就是，我的意思是，你可以称仪式艺术为主动想象。这就是当你创造祭坛时，每一小块你都认为是注入了灵魂的地方。无论你是在创造曼陀罗，而曼陀罗，你知道，荣格总是鼓励他的病人制作曼陀罗，因为它们给冲突带来了解决，对吧？
I mean, so whether you're making a mandala within a group or you're creating ritual dance, you're enacting a myth, all of these things, the storytelling, everything is happening within a consecrated space. I mean, so that in and of itself becomes sort of like a re-enchantment, a metaphor, you know, which is... A re-enactment of the deep psyche, just like the Aztecs are doing,
我的意思是，所以无论你是在群体中制作曼陀罗，还是在创造仪式舞蹈，你都在演绎一个神话，所有这些事情，讲故事，一切都发生在神圣化的空间内。我的意思是，所以这本身就变成了一种重新赋予魔力，一种隐喻，你知道，这是……对深层灵魂的重演，就像阿兹特克人正在做的那样，
you know, trying to re-enact the forces that are under the world. And that was part of the Aztecs, it was part of what they did, there was a process, world making, world renewing, and the world renewing, they always reenacted the creation myths, and basically to give life to everything again, to renew everything again. And one of the things that Marie-Louise von Franz says in Creation Myths is that whenever creation myths are reenacted, recited, ritually recited, they basically, like you said, they bring order to the chaos. And she cites a case of these Fiji shaman when they were, the Fiji people were experiencing famine. And so the shaman go to the rice fields and circling the rice fields in ritual, they recite the rice creation myth, how rice came into being as if, and this is her words, as if, you know, it's like the rice is listening and is able to grow again.
你知道，试图重演世界之下的力量。那是阿兹特克人的一部分，那是他们所做的一部分，有一个过程，世界创造，世界更新，而世界更新，他们总是重演创世神话，基本上是为了再次赋予一切生命，再次更新一切。玛丽-路易丝·冯·弗朗茨在《创世神话》中所说的一件事是，每当创世神话被重演、背诵、仪式性地背诵时，它们基本上，就像你说的，它们给混乱带来了秩序。她引用了一个斐济萨满的案例，当他们，斐济人正在经历饥荒时。所以萨满去稻田，在仪式中环绕稻田，他们背诵水稻创世神话，水稻是如何诞生的，仿佛，这是她的话，仿佛，你知道，就像水稻在听，并且能够再次生长。
Right? They're reminding the world of how it works. Exactly. And reminding ourselves of how the world works. And the role, that's the role of myth. It comes to life, as Jung says, when we reenact it, when we recite it. And so that's something that I bring to ritual art. It's part of the storytelling.
对吧？他们在提醒世界它是如何运作的。完全正确。并提醒我们自己世界是如何运作的。而角色，那是神话的角色。正如荣格所说，当我们重演它，当我们背诵它时，它就活过来了。所以这就是我带给仪式艺术的东西。它是讲故事的一部分。
Whether it's with a dream that's being reacted, whether it's a myth, whether it's, you know, we've consecrated the ground and we're entering this space, a mythic time of the beginning, you know, to bring resolution to the conflict, to reenact and and and reorder the psyche right so that we can find that um outwardly you know in our personal life and and and likewise
无论是用一个正在被重演的梦，无论是一个神话，无论它是，你知道，我们已经神圣化了土地，我们正在进入这个空间，一个开端的神秘时间，你知道，为了给冲突带来解决，为了重演和重新排序灵魂，对吧，这样我们就可以在我们的个人生活中找到它，同样地
this is extended to the to the community and when i think that's the the danger of an ego-driven um you know accomplishment eternal growth oriented culture is that everything becomes hierarchical that you're leveling up and leveling up and getting more and more and more and that isn't one sustainable but two it's not psychologically healthy i mean like those like when when religion is working when a spiritual principle is working there is a descent and then a return you know they're going back to the very beginning and saying you know the egg came out of the water and then we all came from you know there's a reminding whatever the and saying, you know, the egg came out of the water and then we all came from, you know, there's a reminding, whatever the creation myth is, you know, the element is telling
这扩展到了社区，当我想到那是自我驱动的，嗯，你知道，成就永恒增长导向文化的危险时，一切都变得等级化，你正在升级，升级，得到越来越多，而这不仅是不可持续的，而且二，它在心理上是不健康的。我的意思是，就像那些，当宗教在运作时，当一个精神原则在运作时，有一个下降，然后是一个回归，你知道，他们回到最开始，说，你知道，蛋从水里出来，然后我们都来自，你知道，有一个提醒，无论是什么，在说，你知道，蛋从水里出来，然后我们都来自，你知道，有一个提醒，无论创世神话是什么，你知道，元素在告诉
you where you came from and reminding you, you know, of a lot of things that are very human and very healthy to remember that this is temporary, that it's not terribly important, that you're a part of a bigger thing and all these things that we forget when it just becomes about how big can I get the number? How big can I get the empire? The corporate fantasy. Absolutely. And that whole point, I mean, that life-death, it was something that the Mesoamericans embraced, you know, the concept of a life-death cycle. Death is basically strategically denied in the corporate industrial growth fantasy, right?
你你来自哪里，并提醒你，你知道，很多非常人性化且非常健康的事情，要记住这是暂时的，它不是非常重要的，你是更大事物的一部分，所有这些我们在它只变成关于我能把数字弄多大时忘记的事情。我能把帝国弄多大？企业幻想。绝对。而那整个点，我的意思是，那个生与死，是美洲原住民所拥抱的东西，你知道，生与死循环的概念。死亡在企业工业增长幻想中基本上被战略性地否认了，对吧？
I mean, death is part of it. Life and death, it just goes together. Can you say anything about the history of the Day of the Dead in modern Mexico? Because one of the facts that a lot of people like to play with is that it didn't exist until the James Bond movie, and then they decided that was a good tourism thing, and then they made The Day of the Dead. But that was sort of when it became, I guess, a national holiday and was promoted by the state. But a lot of those elements are incredibly timeless, and they go all the way back way before Live and Let Die. You know, and I'll have to rewatch that movie because you're the second person that told me that.
我的意思是，死亡是它的一部分。生与死，它只是在一起。你能说一下现代墨西哥亡灵节的历史吗？因为很多人喜欢玩弄的一个事实是，它在詹姆斯·邦德电影之前并不存在，然后他们决定那是一个很好的旅游项目，然后他们制作了《亡灵节》。但那大概是它成为国家假日并由国家推广的时候。但其中许多元素是极其永恒的，它们一直追溯到《生死关头》（Live and Let Die）之前很久。你知道，我得重看那部电影，因为你是第二个告诉我这件事的人。
So when did that movie come out, just curiously? I mean, I saw that movie in seventh just curiously uh i had to i mean i saw that movie in seventh grade but the film stock and the color how old i would say like 64 probably let me google it maybe it was in the 80s even okay because you know so i moved to mexico in 1990 and um googling it so we all right cool i'm listening to you you can you can talk i'm just like okay when i moved to mexico in 1990 um i was living in michoacan like i said which is my ancestry and the mexican day of the dead was That was an incredible and numinous experience there. I'll just give you a little brief background there.
那么那部电影是什么时候出来的，只是好奇？我的意思是，我在七年级时看了那部电影，只是好奇，呃，我不得不，我的意思是，我在七年级时看了那部电影，但胶片和颜色，多老，我会说大概64年吧，让我谷歌一下，也许甚至是在80年代，好的，因为你知道，所以我1990年搬到了墨西哥，嗯，谷歌一下，所以我们，好的，酷，我在听你说话，你可以，你可以说，我只是，好的，当我1990年搬到墨西哥时，嗯，我住在米却肯州（Michoacan），就像我说的，那是我的祖先，而墨西哥的亡灵节是，那是一个令人难以置信且神圣的体验。我给你一点简短的背景。
I lived in the Pátzcuaro area, which is, Lake Pátzcuaro is about 50 square miles. It's enormous. It's fishing villages and artisan villages around the lake. And mythologically, the lake was considered the door to the underworld. And so it was alive with celestial beings, underworld beings. There was the rain god, Chupitiripime, the blue lord, that was his residence. And it was the portal, like I say, to the underworlds where people went. And so that this many years later, you know, that it was, you know, it has become such a hub for urban,
我住在帕茨夸罗（Pátzcuaro）地区，也就是，帕茨夸罗湖大约有50平方英里。它非常巨大。湖周围是渔村和工匠村。在神话中，这个湖被认为是通往冥界的大门。所以它充满了天体生物、冥界生物。那里有雨神，楚皮蒂里皮梅（Chupitiripime），蓝色之主，那是他的住所。它是门户，就像我说的，通往人们去往的冥界。所以，多年后的今天，你知道，它已经成为了城市，
you know, Mexican urbanites and internationals. It's not a big surprise, but it goes, the Day of the Dead was an incredibly exuberant festival in Mesoamerica. And it lasted for like a month. And now it lasts about two weeks. So to say that, you know, that James Bond gave it life, no, no, no. This was Mesoamerican. And it was one of the most celebrated and exuberant festivals in Mexico, well, in Mesoamerica ever. And it went morphing because this is something I did study. It went morphing through the years. I mean, sometimes the, depending on who the monks
你知道，墨西哥城市居民和国际人士的中心。这并不令人惊讶，但它追溯到，亡灵节在美洲原住民中是一个极其活跃的节日。它持续了大约一个月。现在它持续大约两周。所以说，你知道，詹姆斯·邦德给了它生命，不，不，不。这是美洲原住民的。它是墨西哥，嗯，美洲原住民有史以来最受庆祝和活跃的节日之一。它一直在变形，因为这是我确实研究过的东西。它多年来一直在变形。我的意思是，有时，取决于僧侣是谁
were, they allowed it. They allowed it because they were receiving tithes from the people. They were receiving candles that were being made. They got rich from the fat and the food that was offered because it was a big festival. It was a big festival for the dead, right? Because it coincided with the harvest. And they, I mean, so as a result, some of the monks were all for it. Yeah, this is great. And they had their altars inside their house as well as at their cemeteries.
他们允许它。他们允许它，因为他们从人们那里收取什一税。他们收到了正在制作的蜡烛。他们从提供的脂肪和食物中致富，因为它是一个大节日。这是一个为死者举办的大节日，对吧？因为它与收获相吻合。而且他们，我的意思是，结果，一些僧侣全力支持它。是的，这太棒了。他们在家里以及墓地里都有他们的祭坛。
And they allowed it. And some of them were utterly opposed so it depended on where you were in mexico you know at the time you know in ancient mesoamerica but that it goes back you know way beyond james bond absolutely you know um it looks like it was just the parade so as i've heard that as kind of a fact that didn't sit well with me that a lot of people have said that the movie invented Day of the Dead or something. And it looks like it was just the giant parade through Mexico City. That central one is the one. It's not the holiday.
他们允许它。而其中一些人完全反对，所以这取决于你在墨西哥的什么地方，你知道，在当时，你知道，在古代美洲原住民中，但它追溯到，你知道，远在詹姆斯·邦德之前，绝对，你知道，嗯，看起来那只是游行，因为我听说那是一个让我不太舒服的事实，很多人说电影发明了亡灵节什么的。看起来那只是穿过墨西哥城的大型游行。那个中心游行是那个。它不是节日。
Oh, OK. OK. Well, it looks recent. I was thinking it was Live and Let Die or that did it. Somebody else recently mentioned that to me. I'll have to watch that because she said, oh, you have to watch it. But yeah, I mean, that it has to me that it's a cultural identity and has to me, it's true that it's grown. It's grown exponentially and everywhere. But that to me is also that has to do with the archetypal nature of to me of death. It's in a way that what I talk about it, the fact that it's crossed centuries and now it's in a way it's a what i talk about it the fact that it's
哦，好的。好的。好吧，看起来很近。我以为是《生死关头》或者那个做了它。最近还有别人向我提到过。我得看看那个，因为她说，哦，你必须看看它。但是的，我的意思是，它对我来说，它是一种文化认同，对我来说，它是真的，它增长了。它呈指数级增长，到处都是。但对我来说，这也与死亡的原型本质有关。以一种我谈论它的方式，它跨越了几个世纪，现在它以一种我谈论它的方式，它
crossed centuries and now borders it it in a way it compensates for the industrial growth uh corporate fantasy that denies death and it brings a face it brings image to death that has heretofore been suppressed right it's been relegated to youispers in hospital rooms and the stuff of whether it's finances or the logistics of the funeral or given over to the church to deal with any esoteric or grief. And but to me, the fact that death comes, you know, and one of the things about the La Catrina, for instance, one of the main images, La Catrina is the, means the fashionable lady, and so it's the fashionable lady death, right, we see this, her with her big fancy hat, you know, turn of the century, swanky dresses and stuff, and it combines the Mesoamerican goddesses of death with the Spanish medieval
跨越了几个世纪，现在跨越了边界，它在某种程度上补偿了否认死亡的工业增长企业幻想，它带来了一张脸，它给死亡带来了形象，而这些形象迄今为止一直被压制，对吧？它被降级到医院房间里的耳语，无论是财务还是葬礼的后勤，或者交给教会去处理任何深奥的东西或悲伤。但对我来说，死亡到来的事实，你知道，关于卡特里娜（La Catrina）的一件事，例如，主要形象之一，卡特里娜是，意味着时髦的女士，所以它是时髦的女士死亡，对吧，我们看到这个，她戴着她的大时髦帽子，你知道，世纪之交，时髦的裙子之类的，它结合了美洲原住民的死亡女神与西班牙中世纪
idea that death comes mockingly to us all. It doesn't matter how rich you are, you know, it made fun of the, this was designed by Guadalupe José Posada, a lithographer and journalist who used, who created that image right in the 1920s and satirized politicians and, you know, everyday people and, you know, made it, you know, as popular as it, you know, it is in modernity, that face, okay, because that face certainly didn't go back to Mesoamerica. That is modern, but that's the 1920s. And then Diego Rivera and Frida Kahlo and, you know, different muralists brought La Catrina to life. Claudio Lomnitz, who is a Mesoamerican scholar, he talks about the fact that death is, he says that death is sort of like the the national totem of mexico and a culture that was born i mean a nation that was born of of a conquest right because mexico didn't exist until the 1500s it was mesoamerica right it was these ancient
的想法，即死亡嘲弄地降临到我们所有人身上。无论你有多富有，你知道，它嘲笑了，这是由瓜达卢佩·何塞·波萨达（Guadalupe José Posada）设计的，他是一位平版印刷师和记者，他使用了，他在1920年代创造了那个形象，并讽刺了政治家和，你知道，普通人，你知道，使它，你知道，像它在现代一样受欢迎，那张脸，好的，因为那张脸肯定没有追溯到美洲原住民。那是现代的，但那是1920年代。然后迭戈·里维拉（Diego Rivera）和弗里达·卡罗（Frida Kahlo）以及，你知道，不同的壁画画家让卡特里娜活了过来。克劳迪奥·洛姆尼茨（Claudio Lomnitz），一位美洲原住民学者，他谈到了死亡是，他说死亡有点像墨西哥的国家图腾，一种诞生于，我的意思是，一个诞生于征服的民族，对吧，因为墨西哥在1500年代之前并不存在，它是美洲原住民，对吧，它是这些古代
civilizations and so that mexico had a lot of bejeweled skulls you know it was further back than we have the history and the record of the mythology they're doing a lot of bejeweled skulls, you know. It was further back than we have the history and the record of the mythology. They're doing a lot of things with skulls in this place. So, yeah, so it is. And because there was so much, you know, there was the revolution following and everything was sort of tenuous. Death was always in the face. And it was a life-death cycle. And which, you know, when death is present present whenever we have a close encounter with death
文明，所以墨西哥有很多镶满珠宝的头骨，你知道，它比我们拥有的历史和神话记录更早，他们正在做很多镶满珠宝的头骨，你知道。它比我们拥有的历史和神话记录更早。他们在这个地方用头骨做了很多事情。所以，是的，所以它是。而且因为有这么多，你知道，随后的革命，一切都有些脆弱。死亡总是摆在面前。这是一个生与死的循环。而这，你知道，当死亡在场时，每当我们与死亡有亲密接触时
we we come more fully into life you know we're more conscious otherwise we tend to sort of float around and imagine that we have time to whine you know and nothing is important you know we we feel immortality that is not not real or is illusory no have you ever looked at the santa muerta cults like the not in depth but i i do know about them absolutely i mean it seems sort of relevant that the narcos and stuff would have resurrected that or yeah or brought it to life i'm not sure which i i don't know enough about it but yeah it's it's uh it's an interesting phenomenon for sure well and even you know the aztecs weren't perfect i mean you we definitely you know there's the myth of uh you know corporatism or infinite growth and you know you're talking about but you know the aztec empire was an empire i mean aztec is even kind of
我们更充分地进入生活，你知道，我们更有意识，否则我们倾向于漂浮，想象我们有时间抱怨，你知道，没有什么重要的，你知道，我们感到不朽，那不是真实的，或者说是虚幻的，不，你有没有看过圣穆尔塔（Santa Muerte）崇拜，就像，不是深入地，但我确实知道它们，绝对，我的意思是，毒枭什么的复活了那个，或者，是的，或者让它活过来，这似乎有点相关，我不确定是哪一个，我对此了解不够，但是的，这绝对是一个有趣的现象，好吧，甚至你知道，阿兹特克人并不完美，我的意思是，你，我们肯定，你知道，有关于，你知道，社团主义或无限增长的神话，你知道，你正在谈论，但你知道，阿兹特克帝国是一个帝国，我的意思是，阿兹特克甚至有点
a misnomer because it was the Mexica is the actual civilization. The Aztec was the military. Well, that's so interesting. Absolutely. And it's the only thing we ever learn about really is the shadow. You know, it was the brutal human sacrifice. And, you know, the human sacrifice. One of the things, and I'm so upset that I lost this because there was a British woman that his history podcast had on.
用词不当，因为它是墨西卡（Mexica），才是真正的文明。阿兹特克是军队。好吧，这太有趣了。绝对。而且这是我们唯一真正学到的关于阴影的东西。你知道，那是残酷的人祭。而且，你知道，人祭。其中一件事，我非常难过我丢失了这个，因为有一位英国女性，他的历史播客上有。
And I don't remember the podcast. I don't even know how I came upon it. You know, Spotify just put her there. And I was so mad because I was driving and I wanted to write it down. I should have pulled over because I don't have her name. But a British historian. And she talks about the fact that everything that she's researched says that that's just war. These were prisoners of war.
我不记得那个播客了。我甚至不知道我是怎么遇到的。你知道，Spotify只是把她放在那里。我非常生气，因为我在开车，我想把它写下来。我应该靠边停车，因为我没有她的名字。但一位英国历史学家。她谈到了这样一个事实，即她研究的一切都表明那只是战争。这些是战俘。
So to call it human sacrifice, is that what we're calling what's going on, what we committed, our empire is committed all over the planet? We should. Well, that's it. How is it different? Because we're doing it from the air? How are we more? Because it's more technological?
所以称它为人祭，这就是我们称呼正在发生的事情，我们所犯下的，我们的帝国在整个星球上所犯下的吗？我们应该。好吧，就是这样。它有什么不同？因为我们是从空中做的？我们怎么更……？因为它是更技术性的？
Somehow that's less savage? I mean, war is war is war is war. It's just brutality. It's the opposite of civilized. I mean, yes, we can argue that point. Athena, a warrior goddess springing from her father's head. I mean, she was also a goddess of civilization, wasn't she? I mean, she, she basically everything she created, yeah, of wisdom, everything that she created was to, you know, was for a vessel for civilization, you know, whether it was the yoke or, or the olive tree, the, the weaving, everything was a vessel for civilization to thrive. And the only time, unlike her brother,
不知为何这听起来没那么野蛮？我的意思是，战争就是战争，战争就是战争。这纯粹是残暴。这与文明背道而驰。我的意思是，是的，我们可以争论这一点。雅典娜，一位从父亲头颅中跃出的战争女神。我的意思是，她也是文明女神，不是吗？我的意思是，她，她基本上她所创造的一切，是的，智慧，她所创造的一切都是为了，你知道，是为了文明的容器，你知道，无论是轭，还是橄榄树，还是编织，一切都是文明繁荣的容器。而唯一一次，不像她的兄弟，
Mars, the only time she went to war was to defend the polis, you know, and then she was brutal. Okay. So there's that, you know, I mean, and she had the Gorgon on her shield to prove how incredibly brutal she was. So, you know, to me, so now I'm going to go back to the Aztec, you know, the empire and, you know, everything does have its shadow. You know, the idea, I mean, and they had, you know, the Mexica, they had, you know, he'd gotten way out of, you know, power, you know, corrupts, right? And when absolute power corrupts, absolutely. I mean, it's what happened. So it was like, again, a revisioning as we, when we glean the gold, what do we leave it? You know, what can we leave behind?
战神，她唯一一次参战是为了保卫城邦，你知道，那时她非常残暴。好吧。所以就是这样，你知道，我的意思是，她盾牌上的戈耳工证明了她有多么残暴。所以，你知道，对我来说，现在我要回到阿兹特克，你知道，那个帝国，你知道，万物皆有阴影。你知道，这个想法，我的意思是，他们有，你知道，墨西加人，他们有，你知道，他已经完全失去了，你知道，权力，你知道，权力使人腐败，对吧？当绝对权力导致绝对腐败。我的意思是，这就是发生的事情。所以这就像，再次，一种重构，当我们拾取金子时，我们留下了什么？你知道，我们能留下什么？
What do we learn from our history? And if we don't learn anything from our history, which seems like apparent, you know, in modernity, you know, then we're destined to, you know, commit the same atrocities and errors over and over and over. So what do we learn? I mean, empires, let's think of another way of being, you know. They're not terribly sustainable constructs. I mean, the flower wars, you you know they would have that were basically like football except you died uh yeah i mean you were doing it to protect a warrior class you needed to have a war but they had already conquered the area from they had already expanded geographically as far as they could go so an empire needs war so what do you do you have these flower wars where
我们从历史中学到了什么？如果我们从历史中学不到任何东西，这在现代似乎很明显，你知道，那么我们注定要，你知道，一遍又一遍地犯下同样的暴行和错误。那么我们学到了什么？我的意思是，帝国，让我们想想另一种存在方式，你知道。它们并不是非常可持续的结构。我的意思是，花之战，你知道，它们基本上就像足球，只是你会死，呃，是的，我的意思是，你这样做是为了保护武士阶层，你需要一场战争，但他们已经在地理上尽可能地扩张了，所以帝国需要战争，那你该怎么办？你进行这些花之战，
you go in and you know in order to advance in the ranks you have to catch a certain amount of prisoners and we need warriors so we got to catch prisoners and also the empire's religion is based on sacrifice so this gives us prisoners to you know sacrifice but when you know a lot of the people that try and um sugarcoat it a little bit more and say like well actually you know the people it was kind of an honor that people liked getting sacrificed like they were stoked for it it was like well you know all of the surrounding um policies sided immediately with cortez you know they weren't they weren't a fan of the empire part of it you know that's it you know the thing is when you think about the mexican people and the role of tlacaele
你进去，你知道，为了晋升，你必须抓获一定数量的俘虏，我们需要战士，所以我们必须抓获俘虏，而且帝国的宗教是基于祭祀的，所以这为我们提供了俘虏来，你知道，祭祀，但当你知道很多人试图，嗯，稍微粉饰一下，说，嗯，实际上，你知道，人们，这算是一种荣誉，人们喜欢被祭祀，就像他们对此感到兴奋一样，这就像，好吧，你知道，所有周围的，嗯，城邦都立即站在了科尔特斯一边，你知道，他们并不，他们并不喜欢帝国的那一部分，你知道，就是这样，你知道，当你想到墨西哥人民和特拉卡埃莱尔的角色时，
who um miguel leon portilla in aztec philosophy, Aztec thought philosophy, which I highly recommend. It's a beautiful book. He's a Mesoamerican scholar, obviously, and philologist. So he takes the Nahuatl word and he'll break it apart and he does a close reading. And it's just, it's so in-depth and it's so beautiful. But talking about Tlacaelel, when the Mexica people, you know, when they were a warrior roaming tribes without a home and looking for their home, they sold themselves
谁，嗯，米格尔·莱昂·波蒂利亚在《阿兹特克哲学》中，阿兹特克思想哲学，我强烈推荐这本书。这是一本很美的书。他显然是一位中美洲学者和语言学家。所以他拿纳瓦特尔语单词进行拆解，并进行细读。这非常深入，非常优美。但谈到特拉卡埃莱尔，当墨西加人，你知道，当他们是流浪的武士部落，没有家园，寻找家园时，他们把自己
off as mercenaries, right? And just sort of fought for whomever and uh when they began finally establishing themselves uh flaca he was like the head military guy and and their king the machine king was saying oh my god i guess we're gonna have to pay taxes to this guy this is before they're an empire right but they finally established themselves or you know he's gonna run you know run us dry but we're gonna have to do it and everything and flaca he said no no we're not do it we're not going to do it and what he did he began an entire campaign you know to basically in honor of the of the war god of witsula portly and he that there you see the power of the archetype i mean the power of any religion. He basically, with his campaign, he said, we have to feed the war god the blood that he needs to sustain us. There's that mystical
卖作雇佣兵，对吧？只是为任何人而战，呃，当他们最终开始建立自己时，呃，特拉卡埃莱尔是军事首领，他们的国王，墨西加国王说，天哪，我想我们得向这家伙纳税了，这是在他们成为帝国之前，对吧？但他们最终建立了自己的地位，或者你知道，他会把我们，你知道，榨干，但我们必须这样做，一切，特拉卡埃莱尔说，不，不，我们不这样做，我们不会那样做，他所做的是，他发起了一场全面的运动，你知道，基本上是为了纪念战神维齐洛波奇特利，在那里你看到了原型的力量，我的意思是任何宗教的力量。他基本上，通过他的运动，他说，我们必须喂养战神他维持我们所需的鲜血。这就是那种神秘的
military worldview that the Aztec or the Mexica people took on, and it basically made them the largest empire in that area. There's the power, again, like I say, of the religion, the archetype, because the war god was their main god. But at the same time, right alongside this mystical military worldview were the Tlametani, the Aztec wise men, the astronomers, philosophers, the astrologers, the scientists, the mathematicians, you know, that were the ones that created the social political order. Absolutely, the architects. And the whole point being there was that here they were, they were poets, you know, that spoke in metaphor, that sought truth through what they called flower and song, which meant poetry, right? They spoke in, and these are called disracismos, which means, you know, literally
军事世界观，阿兹特克人或墨西加人所采取的，它基本上使他们成为该地区最大的帝国。这就是力量，再次，就像我说的，宗教、原型的力量，因为战神是他们的主神。但与此同时，就在这种神秘的军事世界观旁边，还有特拉梅塔尼，阿兹特克智者、天文学家、哲学家、占星家、科学家、数学家，你知道，他们是创造社会政治秩序的人。绝对是，建筑师。重点在于，他们是诗人，你知道，用隐喻说话，通过他们所谓的“花与歌”寻求真理，这意味着诗歌，对吧？他们用，这些被称为“双重隐喻”，意思是，你知道，字面上的
two-word metaphors, but nouns. That means a person, place, or thing. It's not an adjective, and it's not a verb, right? So it's different. So, and flower and song meant poetry. And so here these wise men were in love with, you know, Miguel León Portilla said that they were enamored of the stars and poetry and they were captives of beauty. I mean, it's what brought them to their knees. And basically the last 12,
双词隐喻，但名词。那是指一个人、地点或事物。它不是形容词，也不是动词，对吧？所以它不同。所以，花与歌意味着诗歌。所以这些智者热爱，你知道，米格尔·莱昂·波蒂利亚说他们迷恋星星和诗歌，他们是美的俘虏。我的意思是，这让他们屈服了。基本上最后12，
when they went above into the Spanish court and know, court and basically said, well, if you say our gods are dead, then you might as well just kill us because we can't go on with this, you know. And I mean, in essence, it's what we have. It's sort of like a march. Miguel Lamportilla compared that to, let's say, the German people, citizens at the time that Nazism was going on, right? And there were, you know, incredibly, you know, brilliant people right alongside Nazis. I mean, we have it in our culture, you know. Heidegger doesn't hang out or he doesn't hold out long against Nazism. So there it is, nationalism anywhere, you know, it's like, that doesn't mean that there's another part of a culture, you know, we like to say, oh, they were just brutal, you know,
当他们进入西班牙宫廷，你知道，宫廷，基本上说，好吧，如果你说我们的神死了，那你还不如杀了我们，因为我们无法继续这样下去了，你知道。我的意思是，本质上，这就是我们所拥有的。这有点像行军。米格尔·莱昂·波蒂利亚将其与，比如说，德国人民，纳粹主义时期当时的公民进行了比较，对吧？而且有，你知道，令人难以置信的，你知道，才华横溢的人就在纳粹旁边。我的意思是，我们的文化中也有这种情况，你知道。海德格尔并没有坚持，或者他没有在纳粹主义面前坚持太久。所以就是这样，任何地方的民族主义，你知道，这并不意味着文化中没有另一部分，你知道，我们喜欢说，哦，他们只是残暴，你知道，
barbaric, you know, anyway, there is to them, my whole point is, I go to Mesoamerica to glean the wisdom that I can, you know, to put the archetypal lens on, you know, and say, this is what we need, you know, now. How do we imagine this world into being now? You know, how can we glean sanction and, you know, blend it with the wisdom that we have learned in the modern. You're familiar, like, what is it? There's David Tacey calls it the post-secular sacred. But there's a lot of, you can kind of see Jung touch on it a little bit, but the idea that there's kind of phases of human consciousness. The first one is very mythic and magical thinking that we just look at the world and we project our psychology on it and then we don't recognize the projection and we think it's real and we say, okay, here's this God and the sun is about me and the moon is about me and whatever.
野蛮，你知道，无论如何，对他们来说，我的全部观点是，我前往中美洲是为了收集我能收集到的智慧，你知道，戴上原型的眼镜，你知道，说，这就是我们现在需要的，你知道。我们现在如何想象这个世界？你知道，我们如何收集制裁，你知道，并将其与我们在现代学到的智慧融合在一起？你熟悉，比如，那是什么？大卫·泰西称之为“后世俗的神圣”。但有很多，你可以看到荣格稍微触及了一点，但那种人类意识有阶段的想法。第一个是非常神话和魔法思维的，我们只是看着世界，把我们的心理投射到它上面，然后我们没有意识到这种投射，我们认为它是真实的，我们说，好吧，这就是神，太阳是关于我的，月亮是关于我的，等等。
And then that age wanes and there's a scientific revolution of we can just explain everything and distill it down to a test tube. And then we've killed all of that. None of that is real anymore. We can understand everything intellectually, but that sort of fails too. And Jung alluded to this third phase that there's a place that you go into that's hey we need science science is sort of helpful you know i don't want to i want to cure my scrofula or whatever but also um it can't explain everything you know like part of you know and yung spends a lot of time you know talking to paoli about that at bollingen that you know that there's this that science is going to bump up against the inevitability of
然后那个时代衰落了，出现了科学革命，我们可以解释一切，并将其提炼到试管中。然后我们杀死了所有这些。没有什么是真实的了。我们可以在智力上理解一切，但这也有点失败了。荣格提到了这个第三阶段，有一个地方你可以去，嘿，我们需要科学，科学是有帮助的，你知道，我不想，我想治愈我的腺病或什么的，但也，嗯，它不能解释一切，你知道，就像部分，你知道，荣格花了很多时间，你知道，在博林根与保利谈论那个，你知道，科学将撞上宗教的必然性，
religion anyway you're going to get to this place where your intellectual ability to understand the world doesn't save you and there you have to you know the answer is not as some people accuse helmet of saying you know going back to ancient religion and digging that up and throwing science aside that it is to recognize the limitation of science and to trust the intuition of a connection to place and a connection to these archetypal realities, even if we don't understand it intellectually, like even if we can't. And I think that's where we are right now is we're very bad at doing things that we can't understand that we can explain.
无论如何，你最终会到达这样一个地方，你理解世界的智力能力无法拯救你，在那里你必须，你知道，答案不是像有些人指责希尔曼所说的那样，回到古代宗教，把它挖出来，把科学抛在一边，而是要认识到科学的局限性，并相信与地方的联系以及与这些原型现实的联系的直觉，即使我们在智力上不理解它，即使我们不能。我认为这就是我们现在所处的位置，我们非常不擅长做那些我们无法理解、无法解释的事情。
You know, I agree. And I think, I think that's where synchronicity comes in. I think that there needs to be a lot more studies done in synchronicity because synchronicity allows us, you know, and Jung defined synchronicity as the, you know, meaningful coincidence, right? And that being evidence, let's say, that we have of a ensouled, conscious, intelligent, communicative universe speaking with us that we're a part of,
你知道，我同意。我认为，我认为这就是共时性发挥作用的地方。我认为需要对共时性进行更多的研究，因为共时性允许我们，你知道，荣格将共时性定义为，你知道，有意义的巧合，对吧？这作为证据，让我们说，我们拥有一个有灵魂的、有意识的、聪明的、可交流的宇宙，它在与我们对话，我们是其中的一部分，
right? I mean, for us to sort of awaken to that reality and to become conscious participants in the in sold world view and and synchronicity i think is that sort of that third factor that can allow that and go you know i've lived too many synchronicities to go you know to describe disregard them oh it's just a coincidence no no you know it there are coincidences but meaningful coincidences that's different meaningful coincidences that just go whoa you know and there's always the story of the the golden scarab dream that uh jung you know shares with his his client and and who's been a skeptic and more you know um in line with the reductive science and is not sort of buying into jung's you you know, enchanted worldview. And when she tells the dream of the golden scarab, they're knock, knock, knock, tap, tap, tap, you know, insistent at
对吧？我的意思是，为了让我们觉醒到那个现实，并成为有灵魂的世界观中的有意识的参与者，我认为共时性是那种可以允许这一点的第三因素，你知道，我经历过太多的共时性，无法去，你知道，去忽视它们，哦，这只是巧合，不，不，你知道，有巧合，但有意义的巧合，那不同，有意义的巧合，只会让人惊叹，你知道，总是有那个金甲虫梦的故事，荣格，你知道，与他的客户分享，她一直是个怀疑论者，更多地，你知道，嗯，与还原论科学一致，并没有买账荣格的，你知道，着迷的世界观。当她讲述金甲虫的梦时，敲，敲，敲，哒，哒，哒，你知道，坚持在
Jung's window. And, you know, finally he opens the window, you know, grabs what is the equivalent of the golden scarab in his hands and says, here's your golden scarab. So that kind of synchronicity, that occurs all the time. And I think it really does act as this third place that we need more and more research being done on so that we can- How do you research that though? How do you turn that kind of intuition into a number? Because what you're talking about is looking at things that we can't understand and letting them still make meaning. Yeah. I mean, I think that if science wants it, I think if science wants to do it, they can collect data on that.
荣格的窗户上。而且，你知道，他终于打开窗户，你知道，抓住相当于金甲虫的东西放在手中说，这是你的金甲虫。所以那种共时性，一直都在发生。我认为它确实充当了我们需要进行越来越多研究的第三个地方，这样我们就可以——但你如何研究它呢？你如何把那种直觉变成数字？因为你在谈论的是观察我们无法理解的事物，并让它们仍然产生意义。是的。我的意思是，我认为如果科学想要它，我认为如果科学想要这样做，他们可以收集关于它的数据。
What's the synchronicity? Collecting data. How many people? You know, on a certain number of people through their life. You know what I mean? I don't find, to me, I don't'm i'm far too union to to need that kind but i do think that that synchronicity is it can provide that for for the science and the the more depth psychological to find you know a union i do think that that's where that maybe the connection though
什么是共时性？收集数据。多少人？你知道，在他们一生中一定数量的人。你知道我的意思吗？我不觉得，对我来说，我太荣格了，不需要那种，但我确实认为共时性可以为科学和更深层的心理学提供那种，你知道，一个结合点，我确实认为这也许是联系所在，
is is more in our intuition you know that like you're saying you know that you know covid is happening over here and then australia is on fire over there you know like you know somebody who comes from a very logical existential place is going to be like what is the connection how can you possibly say that we burned australia down and that made a virus in china that spread here but when you when you sit with it as more of like a human intuitive thing that doesn't need a logical or rational connection, it's like further we move on this project, the worse it feels. I don't like seeing videos of the dead things on fire as we do this to the
更多是在我们的直觉中，你知道，就像你说的，你知道，新冠病毒在这里发生，然后澳大利亚在那边着火，你知道，就像，你知道，一个来自非常逻辑的存在主义地方的人会说，有什么联系？你怎么可能说我们烧毁了澳大利亚，然后在中国制造了一种病毒并传播到这里？但当你坐下来，把它当作一种更像人类直觉的东西，不需要逻辑或理性的联系时，就像我们在这个项目上走得越远，感觉就越糟。我不喜欢在做这件事时看到死去的生物在燃烧的视频，因为我们对
planet. I don't like living in a world where, you know, community has been so rendered that we can't, you know, even come together to make a plan for a plague or, you know, that you can feel that these things are moving in a direction that isn't good and kind of go back to the drawing board and say how do we do this better
地球做了这些。我不喜欢生活在一个，你知道，社区已经被撕裂到我们甚至无法，你知道，聚在一起为瘟疫制定计划的世界，或者，你知道，你可以感觉到这些事情正朝着不好的方向发展，并回到绘图板上说，我们如何做得更好，
instead of how do we keep managing something that doesn't work you know and i i personally i don't know that science ever gets you there i mean i think that that is more of a felt connection to things um than one that you can you know turn into a number a number. A number, a number. Well, I would agree, you know, 100%. But if science wants it, those are the areas that I say, go there. Look for, find the research there. You know, if you want those numbers, go there. You know, because it is, you know, it only has been sort of reductive. To imagine that we're disconnected, to imagine that, you know,
而不是我们如何继续管理一些不起作用的东西，你知道，我个人，我不知道科学是否能让你达到那个目标，我的意思是，我认为那更多是一种对事物的感性联系，而不是你可以，你知道，变成数字的数字。数字，数字。好吧，我会同意，你知道，100%。但如果科学想要它，那些是我说，去那里。寻找，在那里找到研究。你知道，如果你想要那些数字，去那里。你知道，因为它，你知道，它一直只是某种还原论。想象我们是断开连接的，想象，你知道，
if over 25 million animals die in the brush fire of Australia, it's not going to have some kind of effect on us. You know, it's like that study that they did on the wolves, and I think it was Yellowstone, right? When they got rid of the wolves, how their ecosystem just went to hell in a basket. And by reintroducing them everything came back to life i mean come on it's you know we we have to learn from nature biomimicry you know there's a study that they've been trying to like disprove for a really long time they keep controlling for it when they're like i think it was in the 90s there's a study that said basically if there's trees around crime will go down and so everybody kept being like oh you have to come up with intellectual reasons.
如果超过2500万只动物死于澳大利亚的丛林大火，它不会对我们产生某种影响。你知道，就像他们对狼做的那个研究，我想是在黄石公园，对吧？当他们除掉狼时，它们的生态系统简直是一团糟。通过重新引入它们，一切都恢复了生机，我的意思是，拜托，你知道，我们必须向自然学习，仿生学，你知道，有一个研究，他们试图证明它是错的，已经很长时间了，他们一直在控制它，当他们，我想是在90年代，有一个研究说，基本上如果有树木，犯罪率就会下降，所以每个人都一直说，哦，你必须想出理性的理由。
They've done like five different other studies where they tried to control for things, like where they're like, well, maybe there's trees in wealthier neighborhoods and there's less crime around wealthier neighborhoods. And then you go back and look at it and turns out there's no correlation there when you control for income.
他们做了大约五个其他不同的研究，试图控制变量，比如他们说，嗯，也许富裕社区有树木，富裕社区周围的犯罪率较低。然后你回去看，结果发现当你控制收入时，那里没有相关性。
And then they said, well, maybe the trees drop leaves. And then when you drop the leaves, people can't walk on them to sneak up to the house because they crunch. And then they do control for that variable. And it turns out that when you drop the leaves people can't walk on them to sneak up to the house because they crunch and then they do control for that variable and turns out that when you do it in another season or you do it with evergreens the trees just make people commit less crime and you know but there's this scientific you know existential impulse to say yeah but why we have to understand why it is you know there's not this ability to just say maybe there's a connection to nature is slightly healthier. And if you don't cut down all of the trees, things work better.
然后他们说，嗯，也许树木会掉叶子。然后当你掉叶子时，人们无法在上面走动来潜入房子，因为它们会发出嘎吱声。然后他们确实控制了那个变量。结果发现，当你掉叶子时，人们无法在上面走动来潜入房子，因为它们会发出嘎吱声，然后他们确实控制了那个变量，结果发现，当你在另一个季节做这件事，或者你用常绿植物做这件事时，树木只是让人犯罪更少，你知道，但有一种科学的，你知道，存在主义冲动说，是的，但为什么？我们必须理解为什么，你知道，没有这种能力只是说，也许与自然的联系稍微健康一点。如果你不砍掉所有的树，事情会运作得更好。
Even if you never figure out exactly why that is. And, you know, when you think about it, to me, we go back to the idea of creating the city. You know, how is it that everybody can have trees and clean water and and and have access to to to swimming in rivers or going to the ocean you know i live in la and and there are children you know in in in in south central that have never seen the beach at santa monica you know that's the point is like you know um i don't know if you're familiar with Caroline Casey from the Visionary Activist Show. I'm not. Oh, you want to tune into her.
即使你永远弄不清楚确切原因。而且，你知道，当你想到它时，对我来说，我们回到创造城市的概念。你知道，怎么可能每个人都有树木、干净的水，并且有途径去，去在河流中游泳或去海洋，你知道，我住在洛杉矶，而且有孩子，你知道，在，在，在南中央区，从来没有见过圣莫尼卡的沙滩，你知道，重点是，你知道，嗯，我不知道你是否熟悉《有远见的活动家秀》的卡罗琳·凯西。我不熟悉。哦，你应该收听她的节目。
She's an astrologer. Oh, my God, yeah. She's an astrologer, activist, and just a hoot. Deep and the mythic news. I mean, you do want to tune into her. You can hear her show. I mean, you just tune in, but she's on KPF, K, no, KPFA from the Bay Area. And, oh, God, now how did I get there?
她是一位占星家。哦，天哪，是的。她是一位占星家、活动家，简直是个活宝。深刻，神话新闻。我的意思是，你确实想收听她的节目。你可以听到她的节目。我的意思是，你只是收听，但她在KPF，K，不，KPFA，来自湾区。而且，哦，天哪，现在我怎么到那儿了？
Oh, no. I lost my train of thought. It's not being able to see the ocean that's sitting in there so close to it, I think. So, I mean, the whole point being is that, oh, yeah, you know, why is there more addiction among the poor? You know, it's like, well, make reality better. That's what she says. Make reality better. You know, it's like because it's not.
哦，不。我忘了我的思路了。我想是因为离海洋那么近却无法看到它。所以，我的意思是，重点是，哦，是的，你知道，为什么穷人中会有更多的成瘾？你知道，这就像，嗯，让现实变得更好。这就是她说的。让现实变得更好。你知道，这就像，因为事实并非如此。
It's not. How is it possible that kids from South Central have never seen Santa Monica? And why? You know, and there used to be the electric, the cable cars that went there, that there was a whole trolley going back and forth, you know, on all the beaches that, you know, that everybody could get to. You know, we lost that. I mean, and to corporate greed, honestly,
事实并非如此。南中央区的孩子从来没见过圣莫尼卡怎么可能？为什么？你知道，过去有电车，有缆车去那里，有一整条电车来回穿梭，你知道，在所有的海滩上，你知道，每个人都能到达。你知道，我们失去了那个。我的意思是，归功于企业贪婪，老实说，
there's no other way to put it. You know, we, you know, there was a system. And that's another thing when I think about re-imagining, you know, there are high-speed railways all over the world, except in the U.S., except in the U.S. You know, we have these antiquated, and I think about the effects on this antiquated railway system that we have, and why. Because the people don't travel, and if they do travel, it's expensive, and they're alone. Exactly, and it helps to keep the people separate.
没有其他说法了。你知道，我们，你知道，有一个系统。当我想到重构时，这是另一件事，你知道，世界各地都有高速铁路，除了美国，除了美国。你知道，我们有这些过时的，我想到我们拥有的这个过时铁路系统的影响，以及为什么。因为人们不旅行，如果他们旅行，它很贵，而且他们是孤独的。没错，它有助于让人们分开。
You know, if we want to hop on a train and go see, you know, the states in the Midwest, or if we want to go to the South, if we want to visit, you know, if we can hop on a high-speed railway, we're going to do it. It'll be less expensive than a plane, ideally, than a plane. If we can get them to be a green high-speed railway, then there'll be less environmental damage. And we can find that we actually have more in common with the people that we've been told, vote red or vote blue. Maybe we're more purple or, you know, it's like we have to look. And I think we, I have to, to me that is something that I don't understand is what is it? You know, I heard some, you know, famous radio podcast guy that I stopped listening to saying,
你知道，如果我们想跳上一列火车去看看，你知道，中西部的州，或者如果我们想去南方，如果我们想访问，你知道，如果我们能跳上一列高速铁路，我们会做的。它会比飞机便宜，理想情况下，比飞机。如果我们能让他们成为绿色高速铁路，那么环境破坏就会减少。我们会发现，我们实际上与那些被告知投票给红色或投票给蓝色的人有更多的共同点。也许我们更偏紫色，或者，你知道，这就像我们必须看看。而且我认为我们，我必须，对我来说，那是我不理解的事情，那是什么？你知道，我听到一些，你知道，著名的广播播客家伙，我停止收听了，说，
you know, America's the greatest nation on earth. And I thought, in terms of what? You know, in terms of what? I mean, in terms of propaganda? In terms of me. I mean i mean in terms of propaganda in terms of me i mean viewing your children as an extension of your own ego is not good viewing your country as an extension of your own ego is not good no really viewing your anything as an extension of yourself is not great you know so to me i find it i found it really upsetting but i think when are we going to get our green high-speed railways?
你知道，美国是地球上最伟大的国家。我想，就什么而言？你知道，就什么而言？我的意思是，就宣传而言？就我而言。我的意思是，就宣传而言，就我而言，我的意思是，把你的孩子视为你自我的一种延伸是不好的，把你的国家视为你自我的一种延伸是不好的，不，真的，把任何东西视为你自己的延伸都不是很好，你知道，所以对我来说，我发现它，我发现它真的很令人不安，但我认为我们什么时候才能拥有我们的绿色高速铁路？
Why don't we have them, you know? Or, you know, you've got polyvinyl chloride train car derailing and turning the sky black and Flint, Michigan without water. And we're bombing a country because we said that they were doing chemical warfare. And it's like, hey, this looks pretty nefarious and pretty chemical right there there you go and yet no and who's being held accountable for that and how how what is going to happen to those people in the water and the people and the beings that live in the water and the water that those people drink nobody's accountable in the corporate industrial growth fantasy nobody's nobody's accountable it's
为什么我们没有它们，你知道？或者，你知道，你有聚氯乙烯火车车厢脱轨，把天空染黑，弗林特，密歇根州没有水。而我们正在轰炸一个国家，因为我们说他们在进行化学战。这就像，嘿，这看起来相当邪恶，相当化学，就在那里，然而没有，谁为此负责？那些水里的人，水里的人和生物，以及那些人喝的水会发生什么？在企业工业增长的幻想中没有人负责，没有人，没有人负责，这
like oh no no no, no, no. We just put the blinder on because it's all about profit for a certain elite. All of the giant projects that you can talk about are about an external reality. It's building a wall or bombing a thing, or you need to bomb this one or not that one, or this one's good, but that one's bad. But you can't repair the drinking water in a town that hasn't had drinking water for 10 years which would be an infinitely cheaper project to do there you go in a month in a month we can't talk about anything that's domestic we can't build a school we can't build a train we can't we can't even talk about it you know you've
就像，哦，不，不，不，不，不。我们只是戴上眼罩，因为这一切都是为了某个精英的利润。你可以谈论的所有巨大项目都是关于外部现实的。这是建一堵墙或轰炸一个东西，或者你需要轰炸这个或那个，或者这个是好的，但那个是坏的。但你不能修复一个已经10年没有饮用水的城镇的饮用水，那将是一个无限便宜的项目，就在那里，在一个月内，在一个月内，我们不能谈论任何国内的事情，我们不能建学校，我们不能建火车，我们不能，我们甚至不能谈论它，你知道，你
got an infrastructure that's falling apart you got the slowest internet in the world and i don't watch the news but whenever i'm out and it's on they're talking about something outside of my country which i don't really want to participate in i'd like to fix this one there you go so i mean so to me that kind of a vision i think it's time it's like you know podcasts like yours that are you to find what does a new world look like, one from images that we cherish in our hearts. How do we – You won't be attacked more than if you just say, could we just imagine a little bit better of a world? That's not even an argument. It's not even a – it's like people are immediately know it's like people are me that's not reasonable that's not that's not moderate what
有一个正在分崩离析的基础设施，你有世界上最慢的互联网，我不看新闻，但每当我出去，它在播放时，他们都在谈论我国家以外的事情，我真的不想参与其中，我想修复这个，就在那里。所以，我的意思是，对我来说，那种愿景，我认为是时候了，就像，你知道，像你这样的播客，它们是，你定义一个新世界是什么样子的，一个来自我们心中珍视的图像的世界。我们如何——如果你只是说，我们能不能想象一个稍微好一点的世界，你不会受到比这更多的攻击？那甚至不是一个论点。那甚至不是一个——这就像人们立即知道，这不合理，那不是，那不是温和的，什么
do you who do you think you are like man like you know it's either that it's that you're stupid and naive and unreasonable if you just say like many things could be slightly better and this doesn't work great that will get people more mad at you or there's splitting it's like well you must be a democratic pedophile or you must be a republican fascist and you're like i just said can we maybe have a you know i wrote that article about architecture saying you know that i liked that frank lord wright you know tried to meditate on the land and then the use of the space that the people were going to have and then a higher spiritual principle for that thing and kind of rested those together and that's why his buildings function sort of like altars which doesn't always work i mean he's but that was his process i like
你以为你是谁，伙计，你知道，这要么是，如果你只是说很多事情可以稍微好一点，而这运作得并不好，你就是愚蠢、天真和不合理的，那会让人更生你的气，要么是分裂，这就像，嗯，你一定是个民主党的恋童癖，或者你一定是个共和党的法西斯分子，你会说，我只是说我们能不能也许有一个，你知道，我写了那篇关于建筑的文章，说，你知道，我喜欢弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特试图在土地上冥想，然后是人们将要拥有的空间的使用，然后是那个东西的更高精神原则，并把这些结合在一起，这就是为什么他的建筑功能有点像祭坛，这并不总是有效，我的意思是，他是，但那是他的过程，我喜欢
his process there and my point was like not franklin wright built buildings like alters that it's like architecture is an altar but right now it's an altar to very dark gods you know it's billboards and hobby lobby raps with cheap sentiment and you know i got all this pushback on there i was like you know i went into a school where there were things like windows. And now we don't do that, but we have a TV every two feet on the wall to show something when you could just have a window, you know, just there was,
他在那里的过程，我的观点是，不是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特建造的建筑像祭坛，而是建筑本身就是一个祭坛，但现在它是黑暗之神的祭坛，你知道，它是广告牌和霍比大厅的廉价情感，你知道，我得到了所有的反弹，我当时想，你知道，我走进了一所学校，那里有窗户之类的东西。而现在我们不那样做了，但我们墙上每两英尺就有一个电视来显示东西，而你本可以只装一个窗户，你知道，只是有，
you know, a garden at the school that I went to, you know, and we got all these emails where people are like, well, in the sixties and seventies, they built schools this way and blah, blah,
你知道，我上的学校有一个花园，你知道，我们收到了所有这些电子邮件，人们说，嗯，在六十年代和七十年代，他们以这种方式建造学校，等等，
blah, blah, blah. And it's like, whoa, whoa, whoa. Okay.
等等，等等，等等。这就像，哇，哇，哇。好吧。
Look, if we ever chose to send kids into a place that looked like a federal prison, that was made out of cinder blocks and painted with final paint and had a giant fence around it with razor wire. If we ever thought that was an OK thing to do, then we need to apologize for that until we have taken every single one of those things apart and built a school. OK, like I don't care that in 1970 they thought it was distracting to see sunshine or whatever. You know, I can't I can't speak to that psychosis. What I can say is that that's a problem.
听着，如果我们曾经选择把孩子送到一个看起来像联邦监狱的地方，那是用煤渣块做的，涂着最终的油漆，周围有带刺铁丝网的巨大围栏。如果我们曾经认为那是一件可以接受的事情，那么我们需要为此道歉，直到我们拆除了所有这些东西，并建造了一所学校。好吧，就像我不关心在1970年他们认为看到阳光或其他什么东西会让人分心。你知道，我不能，我不能谈论那种精神病。我能说的是，那是一个问题。
And why are you sending me an email being like, yeah, but I mean, you know, people did that a lot and it'd be expensive. Yeah. All I'm saying is like this is this is insane. You're telling me to take my child to a thing that looks like where we send felons when they're in kindergarten i remember defending that to me why yeah no i i was so struck by that your statement because there is a school there's a charter school about um two miles from where i live that looks just like that, that prison. I think, good God, you know, really? This is where they're sending kids to school. This is it. And this is like in a, there's no evidence that if any green grass around it, you know, there's no evidence and the windows are completely
为什么你给我发电子邮件说，是的，但我，你知道，人们经常那样做，而且会很贵。是的。我所说的只是，这，这太疯狂了。你告诉我带我的孩子去一个看起来像我们幼儿园时送重罪犯去的地方，我记得为那个辩护，对我来说，为什么，是的，不，我被你的陈述深深打动了，因为有一所学校，离我住的地方大约两英里有一所特许学校，看起来就像那样，那个监狱。我想，天哪，你知道，真的吗？这就是他们送孩子上学的地方。就是这个。而且这就像在，没有证据表明周围有任何绿草，你知道，没有证据，窗户完全是
black. I don't know what's on the inside and what they can see from the outside but it's i mean it's absolutely uh soul killer you know and that's where they're sending kids to school and it breaks my heart it's like really this is where they're sending kids to school this is a you know an educational facility it's it's a lack of vision you know let's talk to leon creary who was one of the founders of uh new urbanism And he would send me videos of when his town was like really tiny and they're like, you know, black and white and somebody's feeding a horse a sugar cube and it's horse and buggy. It's like, you know, he's very't, he got out of architecture or you just quit doing it because he couldn't do it. The lady, he was talking about building a school in Britain. And the lady came and said, look, I don't think you understand how schools work. There's windows here. And also there's a veranda outside where the students can go out in the open air.
黑色的。我不知道里面有什么，外面能看到什么，但我的意思是，这绝对是，呃，灵魂杀手，你知道，这就是他们送孩子上学的地方，这让我心碎，就像真的，这就是他们送孩子上学的地方，这是一个，你知道，教育设施，这，这缺乏愿景，你知道，让我们和莱昂·克里尔谈谈，他是新城市主义的创始人之一。他会给我发视频，当他的城镇真的很小的时候，它们就像，你知道，黑白的，有人在喂马吃方糖，那是马和马车。这就像，你知道，他非常，他退出了建筑业，或者你只是停止了做它，因为他做不到。那位女士，他正在谈论在英国建一所学校。那位女士走过来说，看，我不认为你明白学校是如何运作的。这里有窗户。而且外面还有一个阳台，学生们可以去户外呼吸新鲜空气。
And he was like, yeah. And she said, if you do that, then there will be sexual perverts that walk by and look at the children and you know this idea that when you see that modernism and reagan and thatcher are coming in and there's all this way and you know that we're projecting all this stuff and he's like like he didn't even know what to say you know and i when i i was talking to him he told me about um he met hellman which he was like oh you you sound like this guy that I met a long time ago. Hellman. I don't know.
他说，是的。她说，如果你那样做，那么就会有性变态者走过，看着孩子们，你知道，这种想法，当你看到现代主义和里根和撒切尔进来，有所有这些方式，你知道，我们正在投射所有这些东西，他就像，他甚至不知道该说什么，你知道，当我，我正在和他谈话时，他告诉我，嗯，他遇到了希尔曼，他说，哦，你听起来像我很久以前遇到的那个家伙。希尔曼。我不知道。
But he said that Hellman told him when you go to European architecture, the lines go up. And so you're you're always called to look up at the heavens. When you go to American architecture, we put a drop ceiling with fluorescent lights so that when you go into work, you have to stare down into hell. I thought it was really funny. Fair enough. I mean, Hillman talked about the anemic buildings, you know, I mean, he really, to me, his thing on architecture was just right to the point, you know, because it makes such a difference. I mean i mean prisons just the whole notion of prisons to begin with but in prisons the the ceiling is so low what that does is that's oppressive
但他确实说，希尔曼告诉他，当你去欧洲建筑时，线条向上。所以你总是被呼唤去仰望天堂。当你去美国建筑时，我们安装了一个带有荧光灯的吊顶，这样当你去工作时，你必须盯着地狱看。我觉得这真的很有趣。很有道理。我的意思是，希尔曼谈到了贫血的建筑，你知道，我的意思是，他真的，对我来说，他关于建筑的东西直击要点，你知道，因为它产生了如此大的影响。我的意思是，我的意思是监狱，仅仅是监狱的整个概念，但在监狱里，天花板太低了，这所做的是，那是压抑的，
you know that's so incredibly oppressive to the soul i mean when we walk into a church the first thing that we notice is the ceilings isn't it you know especially if you're in a city the first thing when you walk in to any you know fabulous old cathedral it's like what does it do it opens us right up you know the soul just sort of opens the spirit opens it's like there's there's a it creates a refuge doesn't it as opposed to these you know drop ceilings with the fluorescent lights that just, yeah, they make us look right into the, right into hell. I mean, they are, they're an underworld experience. And that's what, you know, how, you know, it seems like prisons are designed just to, I mean, just the whole notion of prisons to me, it's like that all has to be re-imagined.
你知道，这对灵魂来说太令人难以置信地压抑了，我的意思是，当我们走进教堂时，我们注意到的第一件事是天花板，不是吗？你知道，特别是如果你在城市里，当你走进任何，你知道，美妙的古老大教堂时，第一件事就是，它做了什么？它把我们完全打开了，你知道，灵魂只是某种程度上打开了，精神打开了，就像有一个，它创造了一个避难所，不是吗？而不是这些，你知道，带有荧光灯的吊顶，它们只是，是的，它们让我们直视，直视地狱。我的意思是，它们是，它们是一种冥界体验。这就是，你知道，如何，你知道，看起来监狱的设计只是为了，我的意思是，仅仅是监狱的整个概念对我来说，就像那一切都必须被重构。
But so much, I think, you know, goes back to that idea of, you know, of Carolyn Casey's, make reality better. You know, I mean, that might be simple, naive, whatever, but it's not. Why does that statement make people as angry as it does? And it does. You know, because it sounds simple and naive, when in fact, it means we actually have to use our minds or imaginations our hearts our intuition you know to figure it out let's take the time instead of bombing people everywhere and pressing you know people in our you know for a profit let's let's let's reconsider let's let's reimagine let's let's think about what a new world looks like. How does, you know, if we consider that this incredibly beautiful planet that we were born on, you know,
但我想，你知道，很多都回到了那个想法，你知道，卡罗琳·凯西的，让现实变得更好。你知道，我的意思是，那可能很简单，天真，无论什么，但事实并非如此。为什么那个陈述让人们如此愤怒？确实如此。你知道，因为它听起来简单而天真，而实际上，这意味着我们实际上必须使用我们的思想或想象力、我们的心、我们的直觉，你知道，去弄清楚它。让我们花点时间，而不是到处轰炸人们，压迫，你知道，人们在我们的，你知道，为了利润，让我们，让我们，让我们重新考虑，让我们，让我们重构，让我们，让我们思考一个新世界是什么样子的。如果，你知道，如果我们考虑到这个我们出生的极其美丽的星球，你知道，
and we really systematically tried, you know, ravaged and, you know, burned to hell and cut down and done hideous things too. But if we can reimagine this paradise, how do we, you know, create something where we can live with one another, you know, and hold attention of opposites. Maybe you don't always agree with what someone's saying, but we don't have to take up arms.
我们真的系统性地尝试，你知道，蹂躏，你知道，烧毁，砍伐，并做了可怕的事情。但如果我们能重构这个天堂，我们如何，你知道，创造一个我们可以彼此共存的地方，你知道，并保持对立面的张力。也许你并不总是同意某人说的话，但我们不必拿起武器。
You know, we don't need to be carrying AK 47s, you know, into, you know, to do that. We have to admit that we don't know. And we have to just sit for a minute. And the fact that we agree on that, that's where we want to be. We don't agree on how to get there. There you go. And that's a vulnerability that we don't have. We're not, we don't,
你知道，我们不需要携带AK-47，你知道，进入，你知道，去做那个。我们必须承认我们不知道。我们必须坐一会儿。我们同意这一点的事实，那就是我们想要达到的地方。我们不同意如何到达那里。就在那里。那是一种我们没有的脆弱性。我们不是，我们不，
we're not allowed. It's not a, you know know it's not a a way you know to to be you know to take that pause and go oh okay we don't know it comes down do you want to be perfect or do you want to be whole yeah we're not very good at admitting that we're not perfect there you go yeah let's drop that one let's drop the whole perfect notion let's start with that one i think that's a good way to begin well that probably is a good place to end too unless there's anything else you feel like you'd like to get to or didn't and you know we can have a conversation on another topic again you know yes please i'd love to have you on my podcast this was this has been lovely and you can tell
我们不被允许。这不是一个，你知道，它不是一个，你知道，去，你知道，去暂停一下，说，哦，好吧，我们不知道，这归结为你想变得完美还是想变得完整？是的，我们不太擅长承认我们不完美。就在那里。是的，让我们放弃那个，让我们放弃整个完美的观念，让我们从那个开始，我认为这是一个很好的开始方式。好吧，那可能也是一个很好的结束地方，除非还有什么你觉得你想谈论的，或者没有，你知道，我们可以再次就另一个话题进行对话，你知道，是的，请，我很乐意让你上我的播客，这，这一直很可爱，你可以告诉
us more about what you do yeah yeah, that would make room. The conversation would probably make room more to talk about taproot and some of the stuff. Wonderful. Yeah, I'd like to. I'd like to do that. There's not a lot of places like it yet. Yeah, I know. I know more about it. So I'm definitely scheduling you so that you can tell me about the taproot and what you're doing. So if you want to check out the Blue medicine journal, that would be the podcast to look up. I know that you can find it on pod bean,
我们更多关于你所做的事情，是的，是的，那会腾出空间。对话可能会腾出更多空间来谈论主根和一些东西。太棒了。是的，我想。我想那样做。还没有很多像这样的地方。是的，我知道。我知道更多关于它的信息。所以我肯定会安排你，这样你就可以告诉我关于主根和你正在做的事情。所以如果你想看看《蓝色医学杂志》，那将是需要查找的播客。我知道你可以在Podbean上找到它，
but Google will probably get you there. I think you're in pod being in Google podcast right now. Right. The big one you want to. That's the one that I'm sure I've been trying to connect with and will successfully at some point. All right. Well check out the blue medicine journal and then hopefully I'll be on there and
但谷歌可能会让你找到它。我想你现在在Podbean和谷歌播客上。对。你想要的大那个。那是我确信我一直在尝试连接并且在某个时候会成功的那个。好吧。好吧，看看《蓝色医学杂志》，然后希望我会出现在那里，
maybe we will hear from Sandra again. So I'm. Fair deal. With an American. And corporate. Incorporate and shake There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也许我们会再次听到桑德拉的消息。所以我。公平交易。与美国人。和企业。合并并摇动。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。